[Musique]
tout se tient
sinon ce trois-mâts michel muller je me
donne des noms et même en soi soit
[Musique]
ce qui se passe à tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est à dire ça me fait du bien quand
j'arrive de vous et vous touchez comme
ça ça nous donne du courage ça me fait
super du bien merci
alors terriens flérienne et tous les
autres aussi bien venu sur le plateau de
tout le monde en parle l'émission qui
appelle un chat avec nous ce soir
promu
comme l'eau
suis debarbieux
on ne part dieu
son histoire d'amour avec roland dumas
oui au clonage celle ici pour les
geôliers du ciel
l'histoire d'une erreur judiciaire m les
filles
la tamponnaise sûr mais muette
rencontre avec dieu
[Musique]
les canaris trop
millions d'avis
robbie williams je voudrais que nous
regardions ensemble les meilleurs
moments de la semaine précédente
ça s'appelle tout le monde en a parlé
c'est préparé par josé navarro
magnéto serge alors ça commence quand
vous êtes condamné à huit mois ferme
dans la sphère au mba vous allez en
prison et vous raconter c'est assez
poignant d'ailleurs vous racontez votre
départ je voulais absolument donner
enfin j'avais envie de lutter quoi
j'avais envie de leur dire vous allez
pas en plus vous faire le plaisir de me
faire du mal dont je m'étais entraîné
pendant presque quinze jours je mettais
foutu dans la cave
huit heures par jour et je m'étais dit
tu vas apprendre à être solitaire et
c'est un truc de chance quand j'arrive
dans la cour du palais de justice qui va
mettre dans le fourgon
stéphane n'avait suivi avec son scooter
et au moment où je monte dans le fourbe
on lui voit pas que je le vois il
s'écroule le pauvre et là tu vois ton
gosse qui est en larmes
donc en fait j'ai tenu une demi-heure
quoi ouais avant que ce soit dur alors
vous mais à la prison de la santé régime
d'isolement et vous décidez la de vous
nourrir de l'ordinaire de ne pas faire
d'achats supplémentaires
pas de somnifères pas de tranquillisants
pas d'anti dépresseurs et là l'isolément
et terrible cirque et même plus de
fenêtres à ce moment là le lit c'est un
truc en béton qui est scellée dans le
c'est vachement dur enfin par rapport au
fossé à c'était
vous devez donner tout l'argent que vous
avez sur vous à une oeuvre caritative
j'ai pas une thune
[Applaudissements]
mais je vais me rattraper demain tu
files je parle 1000 euros verra combien
je t'ai donné va pour le cachemire parce
que franchement
le seul truc que j'ai jamais pu m'offrir
avec l'argent c'est le crédit lyonnais
je me serai remboursé plus tôt qu'est-ce
qui est alors arrivée laurent là tu sais
c'est une émission de télévision et non
pas grave c'est si je ramasse son stylo
c'est aussi ça la vraie vie alors les
gens les gens ont reçu par les genres
des styles aussi des gens qui tombent
des gens ne lui rapporte pas quand tu
fais tomber ton stylo
on en a eu beaucoup de courage à des
études là dessus cette série pour le
dire a coupé au montage et non pas du
tout je vais pas le couper parce que je
veux que les gens voient que je tiens
compte de la rassure c'est ça le service
public bien alors on vous reverra t on
ça
les gens chez eux mêmes partent à
l'heure
c'est la gabegie bravo un peu la mgb
chômeurs ils avaient tombé la zone rsa
gendron sais rien
je voudrais remercier thierry ardisson
peau pour avoir tout piqué à caux et je
vais remercier elsa pour pourra voir
pour me trouvais beau drôle sincère
génial spirituel maintenant qu'elle est
sous tranquillisants ou quoi c'est parce
que maintenant j'ai plus envie de
démontrer des trucs si la science sont
intéressés par l'astroballe on n'a qu'à
faire le même schéma que moi et donc
j'ai envie de passer à autre chose mais
nous aussi on a envie de passer à autre
chose ça fait ça à tout le monde
comme tous les gens comme tous les ans
vous faisiez votre anniversaire
non parce qu'elle l'avait prédit ça
c'est toujours la même vannes c'est
toujours la même fille
donc est-ce que vous avez vu le retour
de zidane en équipe de france par
exemple je suis pas chercher bon ville
pas un premier ministre
non la mort de jean paul ii des services
un peu mais ça faisait dix ans quand
même non c'est vrai que ça a surpris
tout le monde et je vous en prie
mesdames messieurs en serait mieux de
passer l'arrivée de l'hiver on était
tous
mesdames messieurs je vous demande donc
bon jean paul ii vous l'aviez prévu toi
pas depuis 6 mois
bon bah si répond ma place moi je vais
non pas marrant du non je n'ai plus rien
à envier dit qu'il ne serait pas là il
est là il m'a fait le même coup il m'a
juré ne serait pas là de quel type
sagittaire s'oxyde gère 2 décembre
ah oui austerlitz attend ça fait premier
défaut un emploi alors là il ya un très
très grand changement à la clé pour
l'année qui vient a rejoint bordeaux
lyon
non
allez
bien alors
[Applaudissements]
d'aller au joli prénom nom européen
c'est sa tribu hénin-beaumont jusqu'à
quand et jusqu'à quand
non
[Applaudissements]
obama
autant s'en sortir
est ce que vous connaissez les cinq
grandes fêtes juives
je racontais de blagues eux monsieur
madame reap qui ont un fils quand il
appelle monsieur et madame tripes comme
il l'appelle on comprend
oui bon
là quand même faut se concentrer
benjamin batigne coll ohlala
mon café tu l'as vu un tube à bulles
ces paquets replay petit riblet google
puisse concentrer benjamin médecine cole
mai prochain sur la liste
après 4
ça a changé
j'accueille robbie williams
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir tout le monde
bonsoir au bénin que voler
la ville merci préfère vous le dire tout
de suite robbie williams vous êtes mon
chanteur préféré
you're my favorite things à agneaux et
vous êtes mon âme droite est vraiment et
maintenant mesdames messieurs on va voir
pour toi robbie williams et notre
chanteur préféré didier 1
t
oh
[Musique]
alors
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
app store
aussi
leur histoire
[Musique]
st
mais
chez vous
oh
les
[Musique]
oh
ces tournois
et 30 secondes
tu empêches toujours franches et
en cela moi
est vraiment
[Musique]
a choisi
non
soit 2
c'est bien plus que leurs actes
mais pas seulement
ajouté
c'est faux
[Musique]
même
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant il ya ça
ça
non
oui
tu es béni oui oui le premier
expert de solola
qu'ils s'appellent intended caire
tripping alors on regarde à quoi ça
ressemble please gobi regardez votre
caméra c'est le cas le rouge
et s'il vous plaît dites magnéto serge
magnéto serge manito serge hier
m
[Musique]
la ligue 1
je ne sais
c'est du gros duel des extrêmes
si ça
je comprends cependant je vends car je
n'en prends moi aussi moi aussi d'accord
alors c'est un nouvel album très
éclectique
robbie il ya une chanson combien
entendre qu'ils s'appellent tripping qui
est une espèce de reggae ovniesque il ya
du bon rock
le price to crash de la new wave
cincinnati il ya des balades bluesy make
me piur je crois que depuis les beatles
on n'a pas vu un album avec autant de
styles musicaux dedans hu alors là c'est
rebecca white éclectique je pense parce
que cliniquement les schizophrènes et
donc aussi pourquoi cet éclectique donc
il ya tant de goût différent sur l'album
il y à il ya autant de styles différents
sur l'album que de robbie williams dans
votre tête c'est ça y est
will do vraiment très sympa alors les
paroles sont très solides vous dites et
robbie ce sont les meilleurs textes que
j'ai écrits c'est une confession ce
disque c'est presqu'une une
psychothérapie non oui j'étais aussi
honnête que j'ai pu je suis vraiment un
peu perturbés mais j'espère pourtant ce
que j'ai fait quelque chose de bon je
suis très fier de cet album
en ce qui concerne la musique c'est le
premier album que vous fait depuis votre
séparation avec guy chambers
qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est comme le
nahd macartney il a disparu ce dans son
propre cul
[Applaudissements]
alors pardon la danse le derrière
oui à mon avis à mon avis ils sont bien
peu chez l'oréal
alors désormais vous travaillez avec
stéphane de filles qui est ex durant
leurs années le chanteur de l'ilac times
et vous enregistrer chez vous dites vous
dans votre chambre à beverly hills
vous avez une grande chambre ja oui la
chambre dans laquelle j'ai grandi quand
j'étais petit était si petite c'était
comme un un placard que je ne pouvais
pas dormir dedans parce que dans le seul
champ voilà qui était trop grand donc
j'ai transformé en studio et j'ai
toujours enregistrés c'est fantastique
alors vous vivez là bas vous dites c'est
très agréable parce que quand on a envie
de faire une pause on peut aller jouer
au football sur la plage
l'angleterre c'est fini vous
n'habiterait plus jamais en angleterre
je ne sais pas ce qui va se passer je ne
sais pas où je vais finir par habiter
mon manager je veux dire que je veux
passer du temps à paris et ça je ne dis
pas parce que je suis à la télévision
française mais j'adore paris j'aimerais
écrire un album ici enregistré ici ce
qui vous en met en angleterre c'est la
presse les tabloïds
vous savez l'histoire des tabloïds en la
grande bretagne est ce que vous avez la
même chose ici en france va pas autant
je pense qu'en grande bretagne la presse
c'est comme une maladie il ya des gens
diaboliques qui veulent voir les gens
mourir ils veulent vraiment ruiné des
familles ruinées des foyers malheureux
comme moi je suis une célébrité à cette
époque mais c'est comme ça c'est ce
qu'ils aiment moi je peux
vivre pleinement en amérique que je ne
le faire l'an bretagne vous dites pour
certains fans je suis dieu et un jour
ils vont s'apercevoir je suis un
usurpateur c'est pas possible
vous dites si la vie était juste je ne
serai pas une pop star
heureusement pour moi la vie est injuste
moi j'ai pris beaucoup de temps
quand j'avais 20 ans 30 ans en disant
maladie est tellement injuste et je suis
très satisfait qu'elle soit juste parce
que mon chemin bon parcours dans la vie
eh bien il vient de nulle part moi je
viens d'une famille de classe laborieuse
d'un environnement classes laborieuses
des gens comme moi revenus car dans la
vie d'habitude c'est ça c'était ça mon
destin moi je suis devenu une popstar
donc vraiment heureusement que la vie
est injuste
en même temps en même temps vous dites
je dois dégager quelque chose de spécial
pour que tant de gens viennent me voir
et c'est vrai que quand vous êtes sur
scène quand vous devenez super robbie
vous dégagez vraiment quelque chose
d'extraordinaire vous existez
terriblement sur scène et ça vous donne
beaucoup plus de plaisir j'imagine que
que tout l'alcool et toute la drogue que
vous êtes envoyé non ça dépend ça dépend
tout à l'heure j'ai bien aimé la drogue
mais la drogue ne m'a pas aimé
malheureusement ou heureusement pardon
je joue j'aime faire de la seine et la
saine même ça m'excite énormément
quotidien un moment pour mieux
travailler
l'alliance
[Musique]
ouah ouah 6 mars payent un parfum son
parfum fantastique fantastic tu as faim
alors le 17 juin
robbie williams au parc des princes ça
va être très fort il y aura il y aura
vraiment tout le monde
alors quand vous étiez enfants vos
parents on tenait un pub à
stoke-on-trent pas loin de manchester
et si là que vous avez découvert la
musique dans les jukebox
je vais découvrir les crooners
américains mac the knife et c'est pour
ça que j'avais fait ce disque récemment
en reprenant tous et tous ses grands
succès de dean martin et de frank
sinatra
oui mon père c'est un comédien chante un
petit peu aussi
il pense qu'il est dean martin ou il se
prend pour frank sinatra aussi andy cès
il était comme dean martin et sinatra
mais fauché comme les blés
j'ai toujours aimé ce type de ce
chanteur je pense que j'ai fait cet
album pour impressionner mon père j'ai
fait l'album en tant que tribus à mon
père vraiment très bien c'est un bon
garçon
alors quand vous avez 16 ans vous
quittez l'école vous voulez être un
acteur vous fait des allers-retours avec
londres pour faire des auditions et vous
dit à l'époque je faisais le pitre en
permanence pour me rendre intéressant ce
que vous faites toujours d'ailleurs je
voulais devenir célèbre pour l'argent
voilà et puis en 1990 votre mère trouve
une annonce de casting dans un journal
vous devenez membre d'un boys band qui
s'appelle take that qui vendra quand
même 20 millions d'albums ce qui est
quand même pas mal mais à cette période
vous êtes très complexée parce que
finalement vous avez le sentiment que
tout le monde vous prend un peu pour un
pour un con pour une andouille quoi vous
vivez ça assez mal le boys band non
c'était pas très heureux à cette époque
je me suis retrouvé dans une situation
où les gens avec lesquels j'étais 24
heures par jour ne m'aimait pas
considéré qu'il était difficile de
s'entendre avec moi la vérité en fait
c'est que j'ai vu dès dvd
dans les coulisses
récemment je ne serai pas attendu avec
moi même j'étais un crétin vraiment donc
vous quittez texte daté à cette époque
vous commencé à traîner avec les frères
gallagher les les deux membres d'oasis
vous vous défoncer beaucoup à l'époque
vous vous buvez aussi beaucoup vous
prenez 15 kg et vous dites je croyais qu
en me laissant totalement aller jallet
résoudre mes problèmes
malheureusement c'est pas la bonne façon
de résoudre ces problèmes
vous avez tout prix vous avez pris de la
cocaïne de l'héroïne de l'ecstasy vous
avez vraiment été très loin non bah oui
quand on vit à la maison avec ses
parents dans mon cas moi j'habitais avec
ma mère il y avait toujours quelqu'un
qui ne m'arrêtais de quand je devais
manger le gâteau entier une part de
gâteau ça suffit et ensuite je suis
parti de chez moi cette personne ne
m'empêchait de manger tout ya tout ça
c'est pareil pour tous je la moisson les
drogues c'est que les filles
d'ailleurs été mangé du gâteau voilà et
là ô robbie a été très courageuse et
qu'en l'an 2000 a décidé d'arrêter
et ça fait cinq ans qu'il est clean
bardon bon
merci beaucoup oui supporter you alors
anyway vous prenez vous prenez quand
même pas mal d'antidépresseurs parce que
vous êtes un peu dépressif quand même de
nature non non je suis médicaments il
marche bien pour moi je prends du
plaisir maintenant dans ma carrière dans
ma vie j'apprécie ce que j'ai j'ai de
très bons amis maintenant la vie est
fantastique maintenant vraiment je ne
sais pas si c'est en raison des
médicaments que je prends mes marges
pour moi ce qu'est ce que je peux dire
dos et peut-être aussi parce que vous
avez arrêté de prendre de la drogue
parce que j'ai arrêté la drogue ma
dépression a empiré je prenais de la
drogue parce que j'étais déprimé je
pense que pour moi ça n'a rien à voir
avec la situation afin qu'ils voulaient
c'est ma chimie personnel en tant
qu'être humain il ya des choses qui ne
correspondent pas qu'ils marchent pas
ensemble en moi même et c'est moi ce que
vous dites c'est qu'on peut être sur le
toit du monde est très malheureux c'est
pas une question de situation en fait
absolument c'est ça c'est pas de la
question de tottenham placé et on
s'attend à ce qu'elle ne fasse pas mal
ça marche pas comme ça parce que je suis
riche et célèbre c'est la même chose
avec la dépréciation
en tout cas je le pense je vais
peut-être me trompais vous êtes vous
êtes très sage et très lucide je trouve
moi pour un garçon de votre âge merci
beaucoup merci
alors bien un problème va peut-être se
régler ce soir mais il ya un problème
c'est que vous êtes toujours célibataire
c'est à dire que la la sobriété la
sobriété robin ne vous a pas apporter
l'amour et et vous dit en fait j'ai pas
appeler quelqu'un garde fresnes depuis
sept ans
et pire qu'ils requièrent pierre pierre
pierre robbie je pense qu'on peut dire
vous n'avez jamais été vraiment amoureux
au fond
mais oui c'est comme ça télévision oui
mesdames et messieurs des français je
m'appelle robbie williams
je suis du signe du capricorne ce sujet
là j'ai 31 ans j'ai un bon sens de
l'humour
je fume parfois je ne bois jamais je
recherche un bon foyer alors qu'elle dit
robbie williams en fait c'est que c'est
très difficile pour une popstar
d'entretenir une relation honnête avec
une fille avec la vie que vous avez avec
ce que vous représentez et vous avez une
phrase que je trouve absolument génial
goodson savio moore en ce moment je
supporterai pas de me taper une fille
capable de sortir avec robbie williams
mais ceci dit relation avec quelqu'un
comme si je fais confiance en moi même
chose j'apprends à me faire confiance à
moi même et je grandis également de bien
plus mûr je pense que si je dois devenir
la personne qui veut devenir il est bon
que j'attendais il est bon que j'attende
d'être sept manches et je m'en approche
mais je ne suis pas encore cet homme
voilà voilà
en même temps quand vous voyez
quand vous voyez justin timberlake qui
va épouser cameron diaz
vous dites ils vont être heureux dans la
vie ils vont être heureux dans leur
boulot et vous êtes un peu jaloux quand
vous voyez ça je ne suis pas jaloux
c'est pas que c'est un vieux je n'irai
pas ça quand même mais maintenant j'ai
plein de temps devant moi ce n'est pas
un sprint mais un marathon d'un autre
côté c'est vrai vous vous êtes riche
vous êtes jeunes vous êtes libre c'est
formidable non ah oui et pas de problème
vient de me le dire ça je le sais il
manque que la princesse charmante quoi
son album
[Musique]
j'adore elvis presley ici la presse les
ouazine parisse christine days ago
priscilla karikal paris et elle vous à
dédicacer un livre qu'elle a dédié à son
mari elvis presley you ready
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sans merci
[Applaudissements]
robbie williams il sera le 17 juin au
parc des princes là messieurs et 9 ans
[Applaudissements]
robbie est ce que vous êtes prêts pour
une interview au lit avec robbie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
robbie williams est ce que vous dormez à
gauche ou à droite du lit
hachey en relève en fait sur le roc à
droite en amérique
allez savoir pourquoi vous dormez à plat
ventre sur le dos ou sur le côté sur le
côté comme ça on peut comme ça on peut
imaginer un peu voilà qu avec les jambes
un gros coussin ici et un coussin là
est-ce que vous ronflez parfois non mais
apparemment je le fais un petit peu
chaque soir et je parle en dormant
également vous vous êtes vous êtes
retrouvés à combien au maximum dans
votre lit robes et les amis à la maison
puis a alerté l'ensemble
qu'est ce que vous croyez
vous dormez vous dormez tout nus ou en
pyjama orbi quand il fait froid vous
gardez vos chaussettes quand même non
j'aime j'adore le froid beaucoup chez
akers générale 5,5 euros 6 heures du
matin rue là là là et vous faites quoi
avant de vous endormir
ok je me brosse les dents
l'été est ce que vous aimez kankankan
c'est l'été et puis vous mettez vos
pieds au bord du lit parce que c'est
plus frais ça vous plaît ça oui oui oui
j'aime bien ça me plaît ça vous arrive
de réveiller votre partenaire en pleine
nuit juste pour faire l'amour
si j'avais une partenaire qui passerait
la nuit avec moi c'est son côté vous oui
oui je le fais que ça m'arrive
vous dormez bien en général récemment
pour une raison pour nous tu racontes
malgré la nuit toutes les heures je fais
deux heures je sais pas pourquoi vous
rêvez de quoi la nuit avoue vous voulez
pas savoir sa demande des choses
extrêmement bizarre
et si je les admettent les en télévision
les gens auront une très mauvaise
opinion de moi même mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que la vidéo tripping c'est
bien cela car la vidéo
ce sont les rêves que j'ai eues cette
semaine j'ai vous avez un petit carnet à
côté de votre lit pour noter les idées
de paroles de chansons
j'ai mon ordinateur il ya toujours un
fichier ouvert pour les idées vous lever
à quelle heure entre midi et trois
heures de l'après midi
quand vous vous réveillez vous avez là
la gaule je sais pas comment dire
la gauche pas comment on peut traduire
ça pas tous les matins mais certains oui
à bonn noël copte
et vous est-ce que vous avez la gold
matin ah oui oui encore un mot nage
service bias et a duré très longtemps
ça marche encore
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous avez essayé le viagra
l'assiette encore bassam a bloqué le nez
j'ai pas pourquoi c'est non plus
d'ailleurs
quand vous vous réveillez le matin dont
vous vous réveillez le matin est ce que
vous embrassez votre petite copine
directement ou est-ce que vous allez
vous laver les dents avant je
l'embrassais en retenant ma respiration
et j'espère que la même chose vous vous
aimez prendre votre petit déjeuner au
lit
ah oui vous en faites pas les miettes
dans les draps j'ai déçu je mange des
céréales tous les matins bol de céréales
pour des choses que je sais j pl express
et une cigarette et ça va c'est bon la
dernière fois que vous avez fait l'amour
dans un lycée il ya longtemps et
cosworth
c'était là
[Musique]
deux trois quarts
oh la la la la
[Applaudissements]
oui c'est que pas de taxi cab
thomas kieffer go à nos situations
merci voilà c'est une chanson cocody
et maintenant robbie williams vient nous
interpréter ce week-end là sur cinq ans
restée bobigny
non
bonsoir
hachey
[Musique]
facile
m
soudas
ben
[Applaudissements]
goss
[Musique]
c'est
et plus
ça
c'est un saut
[Musique]
oui
à
m
[Musique]
oui
et
[Musique]
je suis
oui mais
commis
là
[Musique]
m
howe
cet homme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
j'accueille lendemain dit
[Musique]
laurent baffie bonsoir bonsoir cléry
alors j'ai reçu l'étoile que j'avais
demandé ouais alors il faut des toiles
de 50 cm sur 50 cm de préférence sans
châssis alors qu'elle est une qui ne
fait pas la bonne taille mais qu'on va
prendre quand même parce que cing ride
bikes je crois qu'il fera bien dans le
décor ah ouais voilà bien qui veulent
imposer la base te plaît pas dans le
décor alors sinon tu vas me dire oui ou
non vous allez nous aider ça je suis pas
sûr est-ce que sur ceux qui sont pour
qu'on la prenne la main voilà c'est tout
bon on l'a pas je suis désolé maintenant
on y apprend la pensée la majorité c'est
la démocratie ici à lennon à prendre
celle là ah c'est pas mal ça c'est bien
celle-là oui oui bon d'accord je veux
encore sûr de rien dire mais c'est pas
mal je n'ai pas trouvé non celle là est
pas mal il ya un rapport à des missions
spatiales
ap
quand est-ce que ceux qui veulent la
prendre la main
bon d'accord la banque vendu à celle là
est pas mal mais j'en connais ouais il
ya un cas non mais vous je vous aime pas
ce coin jeux et une dernière petite
dernière
alors c'est un bon ils sont fait plaisir
en envoyant la photo du petit dernier
ouais avec une petite référence
peut-être à l'émission en même temps le
gosse est mignon donc soumis ni rose
gold away si jean mignon un enfant ceux
qui veulent apprendre lève la main
moi j'aime pas les gosses à la serap
d'heure vous avez envie celle là ouais
vous êtes boucher comme un coin ça vous
plaît ça non
[Applaudissements]
ok petite dernière seuls allait bien en
fait c'est moi je me suis pas reconnu
tout mais j'aime bien puisqu'il marque
et des clefs de bagnole reis va mal ça
vous plaît je dors est ce que voulait la
prendre ou pas
donc ça fait 3 et 4 avec la grande
d'ailleurs continuer à en envoyer
regarder l'adresse et marne l'adresse
apparaît seins à l'air d'énergie tout de
suite en dessous
je voudrais vous reparler du cachemire
donc la semaine dernière j'ai expliqué
que le cachemire n'avait que 8 % de
l'argent dont il avait besoin et que
même l'inde pays ennemis du pakistan
avait envoyé 25 millions de dollars donc
c'est à dire que nous on peut envoyer un
peu d'argent
même si au moment du tsunami on nous a
dit qu'elle avait trop je crois qu'au
cachemire y en a pas trop
donc voilà ça s'inscrit encore en
dessous c'est l'endroit où il faut
envoyer l'argent pour le cachemire
merci
chacun jeanne moreau julie depardieu
guillaume de sardes
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
nous voir jeanne moreau bonsoir j'ai bon
soir julie depardieu bonsoir guillaume
depardieu
bonsoir vous êtes ici tous les trois
pour les rois maudits la grande fiction
de prestige que france 2 diffusera à
partir du 7 novembre
alors au départ les rois maudits c-17
volume écrit par maurice druon en 1955
adapter une première fois à la
télévision par claude barma le papa de
catherine voilà ça a été un des grands
événements de la rtf c'est vraiment un
feuilleton culte de la télévision ce qui
n'a pas empêché josée dayan ne s'y
recoller avec anne-marie qu'à toi pour
le scénario est la peur de rien jose and
the dap le truc le plus énorme de lower
tf
elle leur fait courageuses n'ont
toujours très courageuse
ouais prenantes josée simon c'est une
vraie feuilletoniste quoi au sens noble
du terme à la faye monte cristo elle a
fait les misérables a fait balzac est là
un souffle comme ça là à la dumas
un peu comme les grands feuilletonistes
du 19e siècle et puis elle s'est
fabriqué fabriquer ouais elle va vite un
way commencé pour les acteurs
c'est emballant ces jours ci bon alors
l'histoire des rois maudits c'est la
malédiction qui pèse sur philippe lebel
et ses successeurs
car tu que les histoires leurs anciens
jeux les plus vifs jacques de molay le
grand maître de l'ordre des templiers
parce qu'ils avaient trop de pouvoir et
le type lui dit maudit soyez tous maudit
pendant treize générations là mais c'est
aussi le combat que se livrent mahaut
d'artois incarné par jeanne moreau et
robert d'artois incarné par philippe
torreton pour la possession du comté
d'artois voilà mais là une finale à deux
filles danthine galana dont une julie
vous êtes jeanne de poitiers vous êtes
la fille de mao avait épousé fille de
poitiers qui est le fils du roi philippe
le bel voilà c'est important d'avoir un
roi comme genre voilà et l'autre fils du
roi c'est vous guillaume
louis 10 le utah c'est ce que ça veut
dire le hutin maintenant le désagréable
le fantasque américain qui n'a pas
vraiment de personnes c'est ce que très
agréable dans cette série c'est qu'il ya
un mélange d'acteurs incroyable il ya
des gens de l'ancienne génération on
retrouve jean claude drouot qui faisait
thierry la fronde alors en plus il a il
échoue il a une tête oui on dirait que
tu fais ma recette avec jean claude
drouot il ya daniel emile fort qu si tu
te souviennes je connais très bien
grand acteur astral hague ouais il fait
un choix qui s'avère de maître martin il
a besoin d'arrêter temps il ya jean
claude brialy claude rich
cki carillo jeanne moreau voilà et puis
aussi vous 2 julie et guillaume ya julie
gayet il ya hélène fillières il ya un
mélange de plusieurs générations
d'acteurs qui se retrouvent là et
finalement ça se passe
ça se passe très bien quoi simon bien
voilà alors qui est extraordinaire c'est
que cette saga à un peu shakespearienne
elle est traitée comme un space opera on
est dans une espèce de moyenâgeux
futuriste avec des décors de philippe
druillet qui a fondé métal hurlant et
c'est vrai que c'est drôle voilà
s'exonère d'avoir fait appel à lui c'est
une super idée les costumes de mini
lampe ica et puis beaucoup d'effets
spéciaux de trucages numériques ce qui
fait que ça se regarde très bien à quoi
je ne sais pas du tout je vous dise pas
du tout une série historique chiens non
pas du tout alors tout est très dessiné
un par exemple vous vous avez la mèche
blanche est depuis toujours une robe
violette intendant pendant tout le film
quoi voilà
et puis torreton lullaby en rouge son
cheval est habillé en rouge enfin c'est
très bon de dessiner en même temps c'est
vrai que c'est très facile d'accès voilà
alors on va je vais m'arrêter rassurez
vous on va regarder à quoi ça ressemble
je vais regarder tous les trois votre
caméra et vous allez dire en même temps
sinon ça marchera pas tu es trop
attention vous aider en même temps
magnéto serge khalfon je sais c'est
compliqué mais faux
ah là là bas ça va mais voilà qu'après
c'est une passion 2 t'attendais à quoi
je peu près accessibles non sur toile
c'est bon on peut prendre sur soi dans
ces moments là je le sens en matière
mais aussi prendre surtout alors
attention donc attention à ton âge de
sens elle dit
j'étais en train de te parler allez-y
bon allez attention à 3 à 12 ans 1 mais
vous le ratez pas non plus dur en même
temps il se faisait le plus tôt dans
l'émission ça sur un deux trois
allait-on serge pas mal dit qu'il
suffisait d'être présents devant le
péché pour devenir victime de la
malédiction du grand maître mot
l'avouer charge pensez aussi à quoi la
malédiction
deux rois de france en cible de temps
quelle fatalité
je suis maudit continent madame favre
[Musique]
m comme monarque
bourdy
mondy à suivre dès lundi 7 novembre sur
france 2 c'est la grande
france 2 c'est lundi 7 novembre et mardi
minorant pour les deux premiers épisodes
alors c'est très réussi
catherine est ce que est ce que je
faisais là ça serait bien qu'elle vienne
quand même ouais
est-ce que josé peut venir josé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir alors je sais ce que
vous avez le trac pour lundi soir là oui
bien sûr ouais messieurs là vous voulez
vos millions de téléspectateurs un ouais
ouais
j'aimerais mais quand on prend trois
depardieu par exemple on a un prix non
c'est pas possible
alors vous les aimez bien parce que
guillaume a dit en parlant de vous josé
il a dit je lui doit plusieurs
résurrection c'est vrai ça c'est lui qui
l'a dit en tout cas moi je lui dois
beaucoup de plaisir quoi parce que on
mais revenons au travail et bien voilà
c'est vraiment un acteur que j'adore et
c'est formidable de tourner avec lui
avait dit et alors vous julie san jose
et vous n'auriez peut-être jamais été
actrice assez dans les liens du coeur
peut les faire financer de denier du
culte
ouais elle m'a fait dire cette phrase
implacable oui disait à tchéky karyo
avec un air pénétré vatan tu as volé le
denier du culte
donc j'ai digéré jamais franchement j'ai
posé ma vocation j'étais en études
machin et elle m'a dit écoute ça va tu
fais j'ai dit ok je vais je vais être un
peu décevant tant pis il se trouve ça
m'a beaucoup amusé à la réserve où bella
merci donc cesser de sa forêt lui doit
beaucoup
et oui je lui dois des personnages
magnifiques je veux c'est une
reconnaissance
elle sait on en a tous regardé branche
entertainment s'arrêter parce que c'est
moi vraiment qui suis tellement heureuse
d'avoir le le plaisir de vous voir jouer
c'est vraiment
voilà déjà s'en sert pour l'effort bon
jose en tous les cas merci on vous dit
merde pour lundi soir et on sera tous
devant le poste merci jeu
[Musique]
je lui dis wououh
vous semblez un peu plus proche
maintenant tous les deux non oui jamais
été très loin c'est beaucoup pour
gueuler comme tout le monde mais avant
que vous étiez un petit peu fermé quand
même devant les appels au secours de
votre frère non non non j'étais là mais
bon vous tombiez fatigant ouais ouais
mais je vous rassure il était way
maintenant beaucoup moins il est
paisible maintenant bien sur wii ah
ouais je suis peut-être même plus
fatigante que lui du coup mais dans la
famille j'ai du mal à communiquer quand
même nom par sms
sinon y'a quoi il ya l'alcool ou la
psychanalyse pour com - c'est vrai en
plus la psychanalyse ça vous a aidé
beaucoup moi il est extraordinaire parce
qu'il dit mon âme est arrêté dans la psy
tous montés dans l'accident quand je
suis arrivé la première fois chez le
psychanalyste j'ai tout dit en une
séance
et puis finalement le mec m'a regardé on
n'avait plus rien à se dire et c'est là
que ça a commencé vraiment en fait
exactement oui il m'a dit d'apprendre à
apprendre à s'aimer j'avais jamais pensé
à ça ouais c'est bien la petite est
aujourd'hui alors que j'apprends oui
c'est vrai encore assez lâches ils
s'embrassaient c'est tout seul devant
mon - ça me ferait du bien au foyer
jeune agent de stars sinon c'est trop
tard merci
c'est trop corps qu'elles sont
maintenant est maintenant je fais plus
haut
le livret l'habitude de tels engins de
payer 90 parce que nous sommes l'alcool
c'est fini alors moi mais moi je vois
que c'est vrai je confirme
bah ouais normalement quoi bien sûr le
lis mais tu es minable mais ça y arriver
j'en témoigne jean bouin mais quand
votre père dit à la télé britannique qui
boit quatre cette bouteille de vin par
jour c'est parce que ça c'est quand il
vend son vin c'est pas possible de voir
cette bouteille de vin par jour quand
même s'il l'a fait peut-être 40 ans
ouais il l'a fait avec jean carmet enfin
je pense pas qu'ils s'amusent à prendre
les gens pour des missions sont bien
l'angleterre en plus belles sont des
petites choses quand il a dit qu'il
arrêtait le cinéma ça je trouve cette
tragique vous croyez que c'est vrai ça
mais oui oui qui plongeait déjà dix ans
qu'ils nous le dit donc un moment qu'on
a fait 170 films dont quelques
chefs-d'oeuvre dont quelques navets de
tête on se lasse en tous les cas tous
les deux il ya une chose qui vous réunit
maintenant désormais c'est là c'est la
musique
vous vous êtes mis à chanter là vous
sortez chez naïve un stabat mater écrit
par par couler par bruno coulais qui a
fait la musique du film d'ailleurs les
rois maudits je rentrais bruno en fait
sur la sur scène je veux dire eh oui
dans l'avis de course à saint laurent
mais en nombre voir là encore comme cela
ça va sortir le 27 novembre
c'est à votre matériel c est pour ça
c'est magnifique
sur scène je connais
il était pas mal ton duo avec juliette
déjà mais je suis champion né samedi ce
soir je chante ce soir à l'olympia avec
juliette magie magie du diable soit pour
vous le dire je crois que c'est ça qui
est formidable en direct c'est guillaume
depardieu et en même temps ici il y en a
une chambre sociale
et oui ça veut dire que maintenant vous
avez envie de faire de la scène j'avoue
ça y est vous avez enfin admis que
c'était votre truc quoi non ce qui nous
passionne le plus alors on le contourne
on contourne jusqu'à temps que ouais
essayez là moi je vous dis fut sa soeur
ça fait 32 ans que je le connais je le
connais donc pense qu on connaissait sa
famille il il m'a surprise vraiment non
on choisit pas ses deux parents non ça
fait maintenant plusieurs et choisi je
pense à ses sympathies sahraouis sont
ces gosses c'est beau une famille
considérait alors vous donc bien
évidemment vous lier avec le violoniste
laurent korcia qui a mis le pied à
l'étrier pour le stabat mater un voilà
et vous faites aussi volontiers de la
scène là pour le concert points 8
bettencourt vous êtes monté sur scène
avec la mer pour vous enlever quoi si on
peut très bien je ferai mon quatrième la
voix est faiblarde
conclusion vous habitez tous les deux à
bougival près l'un de l'autre tout va
bien ça y est quoi enfin il est revenu
sur bougival
ouais mais on se croise des fois il se
passe rien
comment vous les trouvez jeunes les deux
de là à mettre ce que je préfère c'est
le cas moi j'aime préfère jeunes et un
mois par la chaîne pas l'autre
alors vous jeanne ce plan sentimental
vous êtes super sereine j'aime quelqu'un
depuis 18 ans je sais qu'il m'aime
nous voyons peut-être quatre ou cinq
fois par an c'est magnifique voilà
maintenant mais c'est bien d'en arriver
là 4 5 fois par an c'est un peu
redondant c'est vrai cette histoire un
jeune oui quatre cinq fois par an et
voilà la comète de halley cela c'est
qu'ils n'en savent pas non plus vous
savez pas vous
alors qu'en latin on va trouver c'est
pas un livreur 400 c'est quelqu'un qui a
un métier créatif c'est quelqu'un qui a
un métier créatif vous dit autrefois la
passion me prenait beaucoup de temps
désormais elle s'exerce autrement donc
être s'exerce comme en natation
aujourd'hui elle s'exerce à travers la
création un travail travers la relation
avec les autres l'obsession du monde du
cinéma qui est un moyen de montrer le
monde de toucher le monde
non c'est là que s'exerce la passion
désormais voilà ouais mais ça se prête
pas sauf quatre cinq fois par an avec
alors ça c'est autre chose chose mais
bon on n'en parle pas cette émission
cette émission est célèbre pour sa
discrétion richard n'a jamais péché
personnes avec la librairie voilà et je
pense qu'on va pas commencer ce soir
surtout toi je serai un peu ridicule non
franchement alors guillaume j'ai vu que
j'avais signé l'appel des 200 dans le
nouvel observateur sur la honte que
représentent les prisons françaises un
bravo vous avez été en prison elle a 17
ans 1
vous étiez six personnes pour 9 mètres
carrés vous dit ça en gros ça les deux
fois je parlais que de la première fois
là ça va venir
non c'est pas ça non c'est parce que non
parce que vous expliquer la réalité
c'est quand c'est grave et sérieux quoi
la situation se rebelle pas on se fait
marcher dessus est pour le moins on
devient une serpillière dites-vous on
dit un objet sexuel et vous vous dites
le premier qui m'a fait chier je vais
éclater la tête et je me suis retrouvé
au mitard quoi dire qu'on fait il n'y a
pas 36 solutions qua non ya pas 36
solutions il faut avoir de l'argent
enfin c'est vraiment tout c'est un
système qui est un crabe est ce l'homme
maintenant c'est la femme je sais encore
plus un monstrueux la prison nous on
allait au parloir répondu c'est comme ça
genre une ville et il était souriant et
elle seule qui qui vivait pas ça comme
un psychodrame
alors tous les autres il tirait lag est
un tout et et on paie quoi il n'était
pas du tout plein voulons faire plaisir
il se paie n'est pas sur lui et sur vent
mais était prêt mais je veux dire c'est
vraiment l'école du crime et est en tout
cas c'est on traite vraiment les gens
comme de la merde quoi y en a d'autres
moi ça rend les gens
hélas
arif blanc je me souviens tu aurais
je veux signaler quand même que le 21
novembre sortie du coffret jeanne moreau
succès et confidences lors ya un cd best
of avec 27 titres dont celui là 1
il ya un dvd si votre premier dvd avec
des scopitone des chansons extraites de
vos films et un livret de 16 pages
[Musique]
alors puisqu'on en est à vendre des
disques je veux aussi vous montrer la
fin de leur signal des rois maudits
les rois mages dit lundi sur france 2 et
mardi ans
voilà bien alors je ne mens jamais
regardez moi bien j'attends s'en sépare
tout le monde vous êtes devenu
intouchable est une icône
alors on va faire l'interview brûlons
les idoles alors jeanne qui aurait pu
vous remplacer dans les rois maudits
célarié aurait pu qu'est ce que vous ne
savez pas joué et jeunes filles dont
quel film vous trouvez-vous très
mauvaise dans un film que j'ai ton le
paletot gila le paltoquet ouais d'accord
au casting de quel film avez vous été
refusée un film avec rené clair la
beauté du diable
ils ont pris qui à la place jeanne j'ai
oublié son nom
non non parce qu'après la paf et
d'autres vins elle à dire et c'est parce
que non mais ça l'intéresse aux cadeaux
j'ai fait en 2002 ce re quel homme à
repousser vos avances
j'en connais pas oh
[Applaudissements]
alors j'ai appris un truc savait pas
c'est j'en connaissais beaucoup et puis
pas des moindres mais je savais par
roger nimier c'est énorme
comment c'est un vrai génie mais je
trouve ça formidable parce qu'en plus le
génie mais j'ai beaucoup d'admiration
pour lui et un jour vous êtes dans le
bureau de roger nimier je sais plus qui
vient le bureau et ils vous planque sous
le bureau pendant que son avis qu'est la
cité robert de falloir et je grimpais
par la fenêtre je n'entrais pas pas
l'abruti un petit caillou pour dire que
tu vas là et il a voulu faire une
surprise et mais j'étais sous la table
voilà pendant leur conversation vous
unit mieux pour quelles raisons vous
êtes ont quitté généralement bas sa part
est prétentieux mais dès que je sentais
la fin venir éventuel je partais que
vivent le pire défaut l'impatience
l'autorité on supporte mal j'ai une
femme et
l'autonomie ce goût de la saint martin
l'indépendance ouais ouais vous ayez
recours à la chirurgie esthétique
une fois oui pour faire quoi une sorte
de lifting comme ça moi est ce que vous
faites des caprices de stars n'ont
jamais à non j'aime trop être à l'heure
g une discipline de fer qu'on m'a prise
très très jeune j'y tiens beaucoup sinon
je craque
bon je ne peux pas ça les religieuses et
puis pour l'épater mer et puis la
comédie française quand je suis en
donner comme sacré quoi on est ici de
vous les livre de l'onu paris
jeunes et vieux vous n'échapperez pas
vous non plus à une interview c'est
l'interview fraysse un deux trois quatre
[Musique]
mentions lequel était le plus mignon bbc
mois ah ouais il était beau dommage et
et vilaine mais je m'en fous c'est pas
vrai c'est la plus jeune c'est lequel
des deux qu'elle est même mais que son
père c'est moi c'est moi là où était
transformé par la vie belle vachement
bien là aussi chez lequel le préféré de
maman oui c'est vu non je pense pas non
là dessus mais assez impartiale et de
papa ça dépend des humeurs ouais c'est
le pense qu'il arrange a été beaucoup
moins et là moi c'est lequel qui aurait
aimé être le fils ou la fille de
quelqu'un d'autre moi ah ouais ouais
de qui de belmondo alain delon encore de
mille corps devient l'agressé plus
machos cvc de kehl qui était le plus
mauvais à l'école
ouais c'est vrai c'est le quai lequel
plus en rdc par an c'est moi c'est
lequel qui a voulu faire acteur le
premier ou la première
moi je les fais mais ouais ils vont
elles résister c'est lequel ou laquelle
qui n'a jamais pris de substances
illicites notre question c'est quel qui
protège l'autre c'est moi aussi les
nains attend un cd de l1
j'étais là plusieurs fois quand les
bonnes j'ai crevé à l'autre jour c'est
vrai c'est lequel qui était des plus
beaux cadeaux à noël
personne ne fait pas cadeau de noël on
l'a fait mais pas son frère
ouais bon quand même un petit colis de
temps en temps c'est le quelques atomes
est le plus de navets toi aussi à la wii
et des trucs qu'ils sont même pas sortis
ça c'est une chance c'est ok pour
laquelle plus engagés politiquement
c'est moi ouais je veux cultiver ou la
plus cultivée
c'est moi aujourd'hui quand à bien le
contrat qu'on veut c'est une culture
très restreinte
oui un truc bien musicalement tu connais
un mac c'est tout bah oui si madonna
m'intéresse pas bach et non messieurs
karim citant sackhoff obligé la culture
ce que j'aime c'est petit mince mais je
peux tenir des conversations c'est
qu'elle est plus riche
c'est pas moins de celle avec qui plus
riche que lui toi en battant robin sens
inverse des fois c'est le cas quelle
plus la grosse tête
1 c'est moi je pense oui non mais moi
j'ai toujours été mégalo mais ça n'a
rien à voir avec celle qu'elle calcule
plus longtemps au père noël
personne n'en sait rien c'est lequel qui
croient en dieu personne incroyable en
dieu si moi je crois maintenant je crois
un truc de la musique à messam hasard
avec du linge été très étonné le toit
quand vous avez dit j'avais osé regarder
dany boon s'est convertie je trouve
sublime judaïsme en club après sept ans
c'était mon ambition
avant de rencontrer mademoiselle
d'aillon j'étais en philosophie
philosophie brahic et tout ça mais le
salon latence est rien ouais tu as pensé
à ma fiancée s'est converti au judaïsme
ouais c'est le quelqu'un en froid avec
papa site one way en ce moment c'est toi
non c'est pas grave mais je suis
contente je me tapais cinq coups de fil
par jour sur l'argent de toute évidence
ah ouais je pense que j'ai écouté
poliment je te dis bien moi je dis là
j'en peux plus tu vas te garder tes
problèmes voilà chacun san jose
c'est lundi soir
soir il était beau les épisodes
[Musique]
elle entend chez
witting jour dont s'est dessiné des gens
courent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça va et ça va non mais là j'ai si
j'aime bien ça m'a vous êtes en famille
là ça fait 8 fois que je viens
ben voilà c'est ça voulait remplacer ma
fille je crois qu'elle planche et
normand avait d'abord évoqué jean cau
effet la première fois que je suis comme
la première ému parce que je crois c'est
la première fois que je viens pas pour
me battre même défendre pour parler de
corruption je viens de parler de plus
une affaire privée et je me sens pas
très bien
venez avec un livre publié chez pharos
jacques marie laffont éditeur qui est le
journal intime de votre aventure avec
roland dumas et oui mesdames messieurs à
lorient nous a pas là de simples tard
c'est en maudit de la république après
la [ __ ] de la république c'est une
espèce de sa gamme
alors dites moi là parce que moi j'ai
les avocats qui vont m'appeler de marne
jean est ce que c'est vrai tout ce
qu'elle dit donc tout ce que je vais
dire à partir de maintenant je parle à
mes amis avocats donc au service
juridique de france 2 c'est dans le
livre de christine deviers joncour voilà
donc c'est ce qu'on appelle une
précaution oratoire 1
alors vous raconter effectivement le
premier rendez vous avec roland dumas
c'est en février 87 au café des deux
magots
et alors ce qui est bizarre c'est que ce
premier rendez vous avec roland dumas
est organisé par sa femme
ça commence très fort il va se présenter
dans le périgord êtes originaire du
périgord famille une certaine surface là
bas et donc que la femme de roland dumas
dit je vais te faire rencontrer
quelqu'un ayant oui parce que mon ex
mari se présenter contre eux contre
relance présenté contre lui
et donc quand elle m'a rencontrée elle a
pensé que ça pourrait intéresser son
mari et en plus elle avait dit qu'il est
que j'étais son genre ouais c'est trop
long qui me l'a dit plus tard voilà
alors voilà donc roland dumas tout de
suite vous trouve tout à fait à son goût
ma chère christine et mais on vous
prévient quand même on vous dit c'est un
grand pervers on résiste un bon jour en
casanova markit salon vous étiez
prévenus quand même en tous les cas
n'ont été prévenus quand il décide de
vous embrasser la première fois dans la
voiture là vous vous refusez parce que
ce qu'il faut savoir quand même ces
quelques signes s'est pas jetée dans les
bras de roland dumas titre il l'a dit
d'ailleurs le temps d'une gestation et
la première fois
vous refusez à lui sort de la voiture et
énervé mais un coup de poing coups de
poing dans la carrosserie et il dit
allez allez allez retrouver votre petit
bourgeois de marie comme ça au moment où
site approcher ces sondages qui m'a
rebuté et 25 ans d'écart ça c'est
important
voilà ce que j'ai vous avez vous aviez
40 ans il avait 67 ans 67 c'est pas
vieux
non mais sérieusement mais c'est
intéressant ça oui tout à fait non il y
avait là je mets y avait autre chose qui
me gênait et ambulatoire il ressemble à
mon père d'ailleurs semblé à son père
ressembler à son père et c'est vrai que
la réputation sulfureuse de roland dumas
me dérangeait puisque moi j'ai souffert
aussi de ça mon père a fait souffrir ma
mère et mes enfants j'ai toujours vu des
scènes et des machins mon père volage
donc ça va roland elle s'est jetée dans
la gueule du loup la gueule avec un rire
avec un plaisir
donc en fait il était un peu âgé il faut
dire les choses il avait 27 ans de plus
que vous teniez beaucoup ce qui est pas
mal
c'était pas mal voilà vous dites que il
représentait tout ce que vous détestiez
c'est à dire là ma femme l'homme
d'argent l'homme de pouvoir l'homme de
politique enfin voilà quoi c'est clair
j'étais plutôt à vais m'occuper de
peinture et j'étais une formation
musique etc
mon père est artiste peintre ma mère
faisait la fête nautique
j'étais plus attiré par par seulement 2
que la politique
moi je souffre m que roland dumas ne
trouvez pas été assez bons ils
attendront croyez que j'ai basculé
malgré tout c'est possible honnêtement
roland dumas il est beau garçon non ah
bon 6,5 alors je ne sais quoi ce mec
qu'elle loue à 4 des quatre mois c'est
demain c'est pour ça que ouais alors
finalement christine malgré toutes ces
appréhensions liminaire c'est son côté
c'est son côté estate qui vous qui vous
séduiront fatah c'est vrai que c'est un
homme de grande culture
la femme que je suis aujourd'hui c'est
aussi roland qui est qu'il a fait on
regarde la légende pour la maîtrise ou
un chapeau à ses juges ce livre riis est
pas pour démolir hollande humain je ne
fais que dire laver le sait ce que je
raconte ce qui m'est arrivé avec cet
homme pendant dix ans et que dix ans
avec cet homme c'est vrai que c'est un
homme fascinant et que quand on tombe
sur un homme comme ça je peux vous dire
qu'après pour trouver un qui fait le
poids c'est serré moins que cet effort
[Rires]
gilles a
laurent alors donc c'est roland dumas me
séduit par son côté est est artiste et
c'est parce qu'en fait c'était un ténor
raté chaque en fait il voulait
maintenant j'aime pas le monter nos
ratés nous aurait pu être un des plus
grands ténors de son siècle où c'est la
fin pour il a eu un problème puisque à
la guerre son père a été fusillé par les
énormes il s'est retrouvé et chef de
famille et il a privilégié le ténor du
barreau pour nourrir pour aider sa mère
et ses frères et soeurs plus tôt plutôt
que de siéger dans une carrière
artistique donc le côté estate de roland
dumas vous séduit voilà et il ya ensuite
la première visite à l'hôtel particulier
rue de bièvre
quand vous arrivez rue de bièvre ça fait
huit mois que vous êtes avec lui huit
mois sans coucher info faut le dire
quand vous avez résisté les femmes et
rêche préfère cette expérience va là et
alors vous êtes assis au bord du lit
tous les deux et à ce moment là il prend
le bout de votre 5 comme ça c'est une
pub ldv gratuit bah c'est vous qui
raconter ça je sais pas si c'est vrai ça
il a vraiment pris 25 comme ça et là les
trois tomes et qu'est-ce qui vous dira
ce qu'est ce qu'ils aient quoi la
comédie mais parce que non je me dis pas
ça
ouais mais tu es le seul qui dit alors
il dit enfin tu es à moi ou un truc
comme ça non un truc de mcqueen truc de
match vous tient la toute entière là
vous découvrez que dans le proche
entourage de roland dumas
il ya une dénommée la rouquine elle
adore l'opéra c'est roux qui n'a
vraiment c'est le côté voilà c'est le
côté opéra de roland dumas tous les deux
ils sont faciles et d'opéra c'est sa
vieille copine elle tient un club
échangiste et oui alors vous visitez la
boîte de tous que c'est assez rigolo de
visée parce qu'un jour elle me dit dès
qu'elles voient arriver dans le siège de
roland d'aider des femmes qui pourraient
potentiellement l'intéressé laisse les
accaparent par amitié pour lui pour
reconnaître les femmes donc elle elle
était très présent dans ma vie rejoint
me dis faut quand même qu'ils viennent
voir ma maison c'est un hôtel qui hoya
et que toujours un panneau écrit complet
alors je dis bon ben d'accord vient de
prendre le thé et je vais faire avec un
ami à moi qui est homosexuel bon tu
m'accompagnes c'est à paris oui oui
c'est à paris je vous donnerai s'en
sortir bon alors dans vous visiter cet
endroit quoi la fornication c'est terry
moi je me jetais quand j'ai lu cela un
autre est donc un moment vous avez
visité la chambre et la glace santa y
avait personne en iran
c'est juste pour montrer les seins
statut rencontré quand dans notre de
gens importants de la république dans
cet endroit en sortant mon ami on
pouvait plus parce que c'est d'abord pas
trop son trip et en plus il a un oeil de
verre donc avec un éclairage tamisé
donc à chaque fois ils risquaient se
casser la figure donc il ne pouvait plus
il me dit j'en peux plus j'étouffe donc
je prends quand on prend congé assez
vite et quand on arrive dans le hall ya
un monsieur qui était en train de
prendre son vestiaire et on se regardait
avec mon ami et c'était un monsieur qui
travaillait au quai d'orsay
et là elle a dit qu'effectivement il a
dit j'ai du bonbon de chez moi
ouais il y avait du beau monde sur la
rouquine a assez marrant parce que c'est
rouquine il est une relation roland
dumas enfin c'est ce que vous dites mais
très très bizarre parce que par exemple
elle lui fait livrer des garde-robes
entière 1 à la torre elle adore l
entretien c'est sa passion à la passion
pour que ces ténors et lui l'appelle sa
vieille [ __ ]
oui c'est mieux que la culture ne
l'était pas il l'aimé beaucoup et c'est
l'opéra qu'il ait nié
parce que cette femme est reconnu dans
tout le monde de l'opéra du monde entier
d'accord mais pourquoi elle est une
reconnaissance comme ça dans ce milieu
elle peut aider ça veut parce que est là
parce que depuis 50 ans c'est comme ça
voilà tous une femme âgée très âgées est
qui et qui a toujours été dans ce monde
et qui respecte et voilà alors c'est un
drôle d'oiseau cam roland dumas un soir
là il s'arrête devant un porno shop quoi
ils achètent un sextoy énorme noir c'est
par ici
il est à paul il pas pour vous le
caniche et non c'est pour on sait pour
offrir à une secrétaire
ce qui l'embêté qui l'ennuyait font
sucer que je m'attends dans le grand lit
dans le détail et il l'a acheté pour
elle voilà parce que tu sais pas si la
taille du trou le coin le plus énorme à
gaza et en plus il a demandé qu'on le
lui en bail et pas de papiers cadeaux
moi je sais que m et oui les gardes du
corps qui marchait pas parti lui il
était en furie les thèmes et sort des
passagers
est-ce que c'est privé il a quel écrire
lui sert à vous de le dire mais c'est
incroyable en tous les cas dans ce
bouquin c'est le rapport pathologique à
l'argent dites vous
car roland dumas il est carrément avoir
passé pour en revenir à la rouquine là
dès qu'il est avec la rouquine elle paye
tout lui paye rien il n'a jamais
d'argent sur lui ce type là j'ai eu de
l'abus de bien social si vous avez des
chaussures je comprends maintenant
pourquoi le les chaussures berluti là
ils paient jamais rien y'a une fois ils
vont à la scala avec un joint liste
pauvre cas pas d'argent que chômage à un
moment où vous voulez le programme il
faut sortir un billet pour acheter le
programme lui là-bas d'argent c'est
votre ami journaliste qui sort en france
100 francs il fallait délire
il ya un monsieur dans l'assemblée
français qui reconnaît et qui lui dit je
peux vous donner d'amener en lire
monsieur le ministre il prend la monnaie
en lire ip le programme en lui rend la
monnaie du brave faisait que la moitié
ça c'est fini maintenant
il l'a gardé mon copain qui avait six
enfants pour finir son moi il m'a dit
fantastique
chacun ses travers à travers de porc
soccer travers mes côtés quand il vous
fait des cadeaux à un moment ils vous
offrent à un foulard imprimé mais c'est
en fait c'est un foulard qui a été
imprimé en grande quantité à lyon oui à
l'effigié du quai d'orsay quoi ouais
c'est du rhin je n'ai qu'un véhicule
puis magie je m'en foutais non bien joué
il ya des orchidées qui arriva ns est
tout content du cmht les orchidées et
tout et puis quand vous voyez le fond du
sac en fait j'ai une enveloppe en fait
c'est l'ambassadeur de france à
singapour qui lui avait offert les
orchidées vous avez offert à vous sans
même enlever l'onglet j'ai renvoyé la
carte en lui disant qu'il valait mieux
remercié l'ambassadeur pour éviter un
incident diplomatique
judex desk supplémentaires jolie vous
offre une bague par exemple cette bague
bon vous êtes content que ça avait quand
même bon cabochons tout et je découvrais
en fait que ça a été ça a été payé par
la part la rouquine toujours elle quoi
c'est elle qui me l'avouer
et pourquoi lui payer tout parce que lui
il fait en sorte qu'elle puisse
continuer son business peut-être non
gens se sont fait rien pour dix pages
aux orient je sais pas c'était comme ça
entre eux
c'est elle qui a assumé les dépenses un
jour c'est horrible ils vous invitent
chez lui dans le bordelais et ils virent
sa femme avant que vous arriviez bah oui
parce que je me suis inquiété dans la
voiture je lui dis mais on va dans votre
maison de famille et je risque d'en
remontrer du mondial les enfants il ya
sa femme il a trois enfants
il m'a dit non non il n'y a pas de
problème sur mon seul j'ai demandé à ma
femme de deux sont allés elle sait que
vous êtes là mais vous savez il avait
quand même depuis des années et des
années il avait une vie chacun oui il
avait déjà lui l'avait déjà en fait
avant vous l'avez déjà quitté rues de
biarritz bien et c'est vrai que quand il
avait trois femmes il avait sa femme sa
maîtresse officielle est d'ailleurs le
marché que par le nombre 3 3 métiers
nivet il ne lisez jamais moins de trois
livres à la fois il avait trois maisons
il avait trois femmes et c'est vrai que
c'est le chiffre de l'harmonie c'est pas
mal
quand il répondu
à l'époque vous travaillez pour elf
un jour il vous dit j'ai une bonne
nouvelle vous aurez vos frais gaz vos
employeurs vont être satisfaits
vous allez gagner une commission
confortable dire qu'en même temps il se
sent redevable envers vous quand même et
il veut que vous ayez quelque chose de
concret il dit qu'est ce que vous ferez
de toute cette liberté
ouais ben j'y suis allé en prison fleury
mérogis ouais quand ça va mal il
déménage des documents un soir il a
cette phrase il dit quand tout ça sera
fini
nous ferons ce voyage à salamanque que
je t'ai promis je ne suis pas je n'avais
jamais revu que le mec vous dis nous
ferons ce voyage de salamanque que
c'était promis là ça a été un peu du un
peu dur là j'ai pensé un moment j'avais
envie j'avais envie de comprendre
pourquoi il m'avait caché comprendre
pourquoi il avait dérapé pourquoi il
avait eu ce comportement avec moi de
dire là je la connais plus j'ai fait six
mois de prison eva joly me demandait de
lui donner du mage et pas voulu j'ai
tenu bon j'ai quand même sorti cet homme
aux yeux ne me dire bravo vous êtes tenu
le coup même par des intermédiaires à me
le faire vivre
bon si j'ai eues me l'a fait dire il
annonce dans la presse mais c'est une
que je suis mythomane que je suis une
maîtresse leur mi-temps attend prédisant
aussi avec ses pions plus merde
maintenant c'est pas supportable donc
c'est vrai que j'avais envie une
dernière fois il a quand même 83 ans
une dernière fois à pouvoir parler avec
cet homme je peux pas parler avec lui
c'est donc j'ai écrit ce livre c'est
parce que je voulais que roland sache
que d'abord j'ai d'abord on n'aurait pas
comme ça une histoire d'amour disant que
c'est lamentable et j'avais envie de lui
laisser ce dernier message à travers ce
livre
oui et j'avais envie en fait ce qu elle
pour lui j'aurais pas la réponse mais il
ya des gens qui écrivent sur des hommes
qui sont morts
il a l'âge qu'il a je veux qu'il le lise
et c'est pour ça que je me précipite
parce que ça fait huit ans comme demande
se livrent tous les éditeurs du mariage
et jamais vous
je n'ai fait dix tués un mot là il est
là il vaut garder mon pays maintenant
regardons nous regarde et nous priver la
caméra mais non ce que je ne comprends
pas c'est qu'il est là il vous regarde
et vous émeut rien à lui dire adieu
qu'est-ce que ça c'est enfin et c'est
quand même aux plus belles histoires
d'amour en même temps c'est la plus
belle
alors où sont passés les 8 milliards de
commissions versées pour les frégates
écoutez moi bien je veux plus en
entendre parler jugeant très bien sans
moi j'ai fait tout le boulot puis 99
vous m'avez reçu je vous en remercie
j'ai pu m'exprimer j'ai écrit c'est le
plus gros scandale de la vème république
puis 50 ans il est en train d'exploser
le juge avance les commissions
rogatoires arrive enfin
la presse en a parlé dimanche j'ai
appris par la presse comme tout le monde
donc je n'aurais pas fait tout ce boulot
pour rien j'aurai pas souffert pour rien
je me suis battue comme une lionne que
peu d'hommes auraient fait donc pour moi
c'est une grande satisfaction et
maintenant qu'ils se
[Musique]
public piscine des liaisons court c'est
publié sur carros jacques marie laffont
éditeur
[Musique]
c'est ce caractère là à faire une
interview à l'eau c'est roland 2 alors
christine gerland comment tu vas je vais
bien je suis amoureuse pas de moi en
tous les cas c'est fini moi oui ça y est
tu meurs moi je crois que sinon je
croyais plus fait longtemps qu'on sait
pas parler quand même tous les deux non
trop longtemps ouais python s'est pas vu
cette équation huit ans qui paye huit
ont en fait croiser au tribunal vais
vous n'avez même pas daigné lever regard
sur moi regardez ces pompes comme lui
c'est normal ça s'est passé comment on
fait la prison de lester une cymbale
savez ce que si vous êtes un avocat moi
c'est moins dur que je conduis quand
même dans la chance d'être relaxé bah
ouais tu m'en veux un peu
y'a pas de mots pour le dire
ah oui tu m'en veux là c'est pas content
tu sais tu m'aimes plus de la haine
c'est même plus vous j'ai pitié
tu m'en veux pas trop quand même
chapitre en gros tu là regrette notre
histoire
non tu te rappelles quad notre histoire
est bon moment mais quand on marche et
sur les plages du cap ferret et qu'on
regarder passer les nuages la main dans
la main que j'avais la naïveté de croire
au destin durée déterminée mais 83 ans
j'ai un début d'érection
dis-moi christine tu penses que sans moi
je serais devenu célèbre
je m'en fous de la célébrité mois alors
il paraît que tu as encore faire un
livre là oui ça parle de moi j'imagine
oui et c'est le dernier
tu dis quoi tu dis tous là je dis non
que vous êtes quitté qui était à la fois
ange et démon
ouais honnêtement tu crois que ça
intéresse les gens notre histoire
christine franchement pas forcément mais
moi je suis fait plaisir sans rire
christine qu'est ce que tu m'as trouvé
j'avais 60 70 en avait 40 qu'est ce que
tu m'as trouvé franchement encore
j'étais excité vraiment tu faisais
semblant fait foi
j'ai encore lu mais là encore vous faire
un compliment ouais il ya des mecs de 30
ans qui aurait pu vous en venir là ça me
fait plaisir qu'il dit c'est donc avec
moi taz avait simulé finalement et non
et là je suis content tu pourras me
pardonner un jeu au christine dans un
prochain livre
on l'écrit ensemble non je pense pas
j'ai oublié je veux plus en parler
dis moi j'ai écouté ton disque là qu'est
ce qui se passe il veut retourner en
prison voilà pourquoi vous insistez avec
ça je vous ai fais parce que j'aime bien
me taquiner tu te souviens qu'est ce que
tu aimerais me dit aujourd'hui sérieux
en bourse à rembourser ce que tu vis ou
maintenant j'ai ben je vis nulle part à
une boîte à chaussures
elle adore ça ouais j'ai une boîte
achèterait je vis chez ta mère c'est ça
non non surtout pas ouais elle te veux
plus
manon la maison est pleine ou non je
suis dedans avec des amis qui m'héberge
c'est un nouveau mac
oui ça va j'y croyais plus
il faut jamais découragé tu vois on peut
toujours tomber amoureux
jane fonda est venu ici tombe amoureuse
de baffie et comment il est tombé à
qu'il est mieux que moi il n allait plus
dix mois sérieux t'a baiser avec
d'autres ministres à part moi très
baiser avec un ministre mais qui n'était
pas encore ministre c'était le mon
premier mari ah ouais peretti ministre
des transports il ya un truc que je
comprends pas brett a vendu le pognon
parce que l'argent je m'en fous ouais
il ya moyen qu'on se revoie l'un pour
quoi faire vous prenez du viagra sans
blague au long du match r disons non
puis si les gens courent les amants
maudits journal intime ses parents
jacques baril
à 8 heures
[Musique]
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe celle là
vous devez appeler votre main en direct
sur le plateau
bâle va être ravie j'ai pas l'appeler ta
main oui tiens vas-y
ça va lui faire plaisir mois s'appelle t
maman 60 pol pot le pôle que ce qu'il
faut avec roland dumas maman je suis sur
le plateau de thierry ardisson qui
tombera et j'ai une carte tu sais on
tire des cartes et il fallait que
j'appelle ma mère donc je t'appelle
étiré terreur dit sont embrassés et puis
très fort voilà et puis bon c'était
m'engage je le fais non il eu un truc la
peau voiture pas la piposa ta mère voilà
ce que je lui dis ça c'est tiré alors
attends je te passe au tiré en deux
temps
[Applaudissements]
allo bonsoir paul comment ça va voilà lé
content de me parler de la mer ouais ça
me fait plaisir non on est en train de
parler de son livre a eu très bien son
livre qu'est ce qui lui a fait passer
l'autre quand même
elle a du courage parce que franchement
elle est courageuse 1 ça fait huit ans
qui lui a pas donné signe de vie
honnêtement demander où les mineurs
attendent et non pas qu'on attendait est
ce que vous savez où elle a planqué le
pognon que non elle s'est pas sentie
jardin elle a regardé par le jardin non
bon et tout le monde veut dire bonsoir
paul bonsoir à bientôt portez vous bien
oui c'est ma ville
[Musique]
il est la vôtre jus et là il m'a
accompagné oui pourquoi laurence parce
qu'on veut le voir maintenant il parle
pas le français et c'est pas grave
[Musique]
baby boom
mais comment il s'appelle
elle
[Applaudissements]
à
ouais
bon c'est quoi ces pompes il parle pas
français
ils portent en général il parle plutôt
du moon boots à segura le qinghai vous
êtes un amoureux des gauchistes very
rich ricci
elle a donné l'argent chez game the
money back business guerlain chicherit
dati elle a beaucoup de coeur et diomède
club aurait dit non elle
what is your job je suis un musicien une
semaine plusieurs instruments thestreet
vois mes bambins à c'était un homme
orchestre un gilet
[Applaudissements]
je m'attends à rien vu de votre futur
aussi qui est la vapeur d'eau charrette
c'est hallucinant ce qui m'arrive est
mieux que le vieux à laisse tomber ouais
les norvégiens comme eva joly ouais il
est venu l'ennuyer sur son terrain
maintenant je vais sur le sien voilà
comment tu le trouves julie baille
amélie bleus wen dans le côté spécial
une autre spécialiste en musicien julie
vrai mais je n'ai pas entendu pas mal
fait du bien elle est heureusement je
suis très heureuse bon bah écoutes je là
dedans tu autres pensionnaires habituels
retrouver très vite
j'accueille bernard debré
bonsoir bernard debré vous connaissez
christine deviers-joncour on a entendu
parler si roland dumas à je connais le
lendemain vous allez en apprendre de
belles en lisant le bouquin il prend le
soleil pour un chirurgien vous avez les
vidéos de vous qui sont endormis mais le
groupe d'amis chez ça peut vous
surprendre quand même ce qui est d'une
taille extraordinaire est tout noir bien
alors bonsoir professeur jeudi tout ce
qui est sur ma fiche
bonsoir professeur vous ment soir êtes
chef du service neurologie à l'hôpital
cochin ancien ministre député de paris
auteur de nombreux ouvrages et vous
publié aujourd'hui au cherche midi
la revanche du serpent ou la fin de
l'homo sapiens
alors ce que vous dites cs est important
c'est vous dites qu'il ya quatre
découvertes qui ont permis une
révolution l'adn en 1940 les lys en 1953
l'acide ribonucléique en 65 et le génome
le décryptage du génome en 2003 c'est
vraiment des dates importantes parce que
c'est une révolution car une révolution
parce que maintenant on a compris
comment était fabriquée l'homme et on a
su et on le sait lire le grand livre de
l'homme voilà alors on a su d'abord on
connaître les lettres ouais
puis les phrases ouais et puis
maintenant on connaît les fautes
d'orthographe
voilà maintenant qu'on connaît les
photographes on va pouvoir un jour les
corriger vous dites qu aujourd'hui grâce
à cette connaissance l'homme peut être
corrigé ce qui est quand même
effectivement il a déjà été fait mais je
rappelle ici simplement l'histoire des
bébés bulles vous savez c'est bien et
qui sont nés sans immunité à qui on a
corrigé un déficit immunitaire
c'est assez extraordinaire sens et b
étaient condamnés à mort et ils sont
sortis de leur bulle
voilà alors c'est aussi la source de
nombreuses inquiétudes de nombreux
angoisse parce que tout de suite quand
on parle de ça il ya les mots qui font
peur quoi manipulations génétiques
eugénisme clonage évidemment alors vous
vous vous distinguez 2 clonage le
clonage reproductif et le clonage
thérapeutique alors le clonage
reproductif
c'est évidemment la duplication de
l'homme sans fécondation vous le
déplorez mais vous savez bien qu'il est
inéluctable si on vous dit que de toute
façon quelque part il ya sûrement des
fou furieux qui sont en train de
connaître un bébé bien entendu d'abord
on a cloné les animaux ouais vous savez
que pour coller d'hollywood au lit mais
maintenant aux états unis vous avez un
chien qui l'aurait et vous avez vous
payé 50 mille dollars et vous avez le
clone de votre chien qui vient de mourir
donc ça c'est le saas et le clonage
reproductif mais il ya aussi et ça c'est
beaucoup plus important le clonage
thérapeutique
alors pour vous c'est le cas de le dire
c'est la panacée universelle
l'idée c'est d'utiliser les cellules
souches c'est à dire les cellules du
foetus
avant qu'elle se spécialise puisqu'au
départ toutes cellules sont
indifférenciés et après elle se
spécialise d'abord la cellule l'oeuf
c'est un spermatozoïde et d'un ovule se
constitue un 9 9 avec tout dedans c'est
une cellule comme une autre mais il ya
tout on sait qu'elle va se diviser et
pendant une dizaine de jours 14 jours
les cellules qui se divisent reste
indifférenciée elles ont toutes les
potentialités humaines on enlève une
on recrée un homme et puis au bout de 14
jours sans qu'on sache pourquoi les
cellules deviennent un brin un cerveau
en descente les terrasses et pas très
bien pour toi j'ai vu ça j'ai vingt dix
si vous voyez des silures qui se met à
battre à des cellules du myocarde qui a
passé d'un moment se met 7 bat comme un
petit gars à terry est ce que vous
imaginez qu'on peut prendre
effectivement pour l'instant des
embryons congelés décongèle ce sont des
embrouilles ans à 4 cellules ou 8
cellules
ou est ce que c'est un homme ou pas moi
je considère que ce n'est encore rien et
de cette cellule là on va fabriquer un
coeur un rien fois ça c'est très bien ça
sera pas complètement possible pour
l'homme parce que l'homme a une certaine
différence avec l'embryon mais on va
prendre une de vos cellules d'un jour
une vos cellules de peau on à faire
régresser en cellules souches
1 c'est comme ça qu'on a fait de lit et
après la faire repartir vers le choix
qui vous manquent
tiens on va pas si bien dire bernard
exactement c'est pour ça comme il n'ya
pas d'alcool l'a pour l'instant et si
jamais aussi bon ou le coeur qui
flambait par exemple refait un coeur et
ça ça sera votre coeur
le problème est là le problème c'est
qu'on pourra certainement et on peut
déjà faire les cellules cérébrales et on
pourra traiter l'alzheimer on pourra
traiter le parkinson pas qu'on est trop
tôt là on est dans un espace au début
mais on est pour l'instant mais on est
en train de faire on est en train de
faire
faut pas le cacher ses seins et celles à
venir sélectionneur sait pas quand on va
traiter toutes les maladies en fait
grâce à ses cellules
une fois faisant de la rigolade auto
reproduit une autre réparation
bref faire des greffes de peau bien sûr
lucky vêlage héros ouais vas y aménagea
même c'est que la loi française sur la
bioéthique interdit qu'on manipule ces
cellules au delà du quatorzième jour
alors ça c'est un peu bizarre parce
qu'on a le droit d'avorter pendant
beaucoup plus longtemps et en fait là ça
s'arrête le 14e parce que au 14e jour
laissez-nous se différencie de mai à
partir du 14e jour elle se spécialise
alors si vous en avez une
mais il manquera un browser ça c'est
évidemment très schématique donc on nous
dit vous ne touchez plus nous sommes
quasiment le seul pays à voir cette
interdiction on est en vie et nous avons
cinq six sept ans de retard alors c'est
pas terrible parce que heureusement dans
les autres pays ce sont souvent les
chercheurs français qui sont en train de
faire des recherches
ce qui est un peu bizarre quand même
c'est qu'en france on n'interdit donc de
toucher à ces cellules au delà du
quatorzième jour et malgré tout on est
d'accord en france sur l'enfant
médicaments oui l'informer des gammes en
est très simple il ya deux exemples le
premier exemple et aux états unis un
couple avait une jeune fille de sept ans
qui était atteint d'une leucémie ne
s'est mis assez grave et on n'arrivait
pas à trouver de moelle osseuse pour lui
greffer sam annoncé une nouvelle moelle
osseuse pour les guérir nous comment
vous n'avez pas en trouver on a demandé
au couple de faire des embryons alors on
a fait après un tri d'embryons nar est
implantée à la femme l'embryon qu'on
avait sélectionné parce qu'on savait que
cet enfant qui allait naître en ruine
moelle compatible avec celle de sa soeur
créé des enfants pour réparer les autres
à ancrer les enfants oui mais l'enfant
vit
il est très content et les oiseaux et la
jeune femme la jeune fille maintenance
une jeune femme est vivante elle a été
sauvée par la naissance de son frère il
ya un autre exemple aussi c'est cette
famille qu'avec eux des enfants
qu'avaient des maladies génétiques tout
à fait trois enfants de suite avec des
maladies génétiques sont morts qui sont
morts au quatrième on fait un enfant en
médicaments pour pour sauver on vient
nous voir nous disant voilà première
enfant il est mort à l'âge de 7 ans
d'une leucodystrophie ce terme un peu
barbare deuxième aussi troisième aussi
on aimerait avoir un enfant normes
donc on a fait une fécondation in vitro
on a choisi
l'enfant qui n'était pas atteint 16 pas
un enfant médicament l'annoncent comme
non c'est un enfant qui est injustement
sur le clonage vous dites faut faire
attention il faut pas confondre le
clonage reproductif avec le clonage
thérapeutique et c'est un peu la même
réflexion vous avez sur l'eugénisme
l'eugénisme viviane auger nisme
totalitaire nazi
c'est à dire on élimine tous les gens
qui sont pas normaux enfin inscrit en
asie nazis s'étaient pouvant table c'est
du fascisme c'était tout ce qu'il ya de
plus horrible mais en suède jusqu'en
1975 est vrai les femmes qui était
asocial qui avait beaucoup d'enfants qui
ai fait beaucoup d'appartements
on leur disait on veut bien vous traitez
mais il faut vous stérilisés voilà il
faut pas mettre au monde etc jusqu'à 75
et ça c'était du totalitarisme c'est du
fascisme donc ça vous dit c'est le geste
de totalitaire voilà voilà
et vous dites y'a un génie ce que vous
appelez de liberté ce qui est un mot bon
enfin bon on avait laissé la liberté de
voir et si l'échographie c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui que tout le monde
pratique l'eugénisme
parce que quand une femme fait une
amniocentèse qu'on trouve que finalement
l'enfant va être anormalement général
elles avortent ne l'a pas le garder
c'est donc c'est déjà ce que vous dites
en fait c'est que des mots comme clonage
sont pas obligatoirement négatif quand
il est thérapeutique et des mous comme
eugénisme sont pas obligatoirement
négatif quand c'est un euphémisme de
liberté qui est celui qui pratique
toutes les âmes en faisant des
aménagements un exemple tiens une femme
enceinte
maintenant on lui fait une prise de sang
c'est simple ouais et dont le champ de
cette femme on va trouver les cellules
du foetus et comme on trouve la cellule
du foetus
on va pouvoir livre lire le grand lit
de l'avis de ce foetus on va voir s'il
sera atteint d'une maladie à la
naissance un peu plus tard s'il sera
atteint d'une maladie
peut-être même à 40 ou 45 ans aura si on
a un exemple je prends un exemple un
couple de nous voir en disant ma mère a
une maladie d alzheimer précoce 50 ans
mon père a une maladie d'alzheimer
précoce et des deux côtés et donc nous
nous savons aussi que nous sommes
atteints de cette maladie et nous allons
la développer à 50 ans on voudrait que
nos enfants ne développe pas donc il ya
eu une fécondation in vitro tri
d'embryons et on a sélectionné l'embryon
et les embryons qui n'avait pas cette
maladie d'alzheimer précoce alors est ce
qu'on a le droit de le faire
est ce qu'on a le droit de refuser de le
faire alors oui je crois que oui on a le
droit de le fait et ça je pense que
c'est un peu la liberté de la femme
alors maintenant qu'on puis on peut
savoir par le sang circule en voyez un
paradoxe
la femme a le droit d'avoir quelques
jusqu'à 12 semaines et en suède jusqu'à
22 semaines
moi je suis favorable à l'avortement je
vous le dis très simplement pour une
raison également simple c'est que quand
j'étais de garde à l'hôpital et qu'on
voyait des jeunes filles de 15 ans qui
s'était fait avorter dans une arrière
boutique de feu de sedan et qui venait
mourir à l'hôpital que je trouvais ça
insupportable ce lien de sang
l'avortement est et est un droit et dans
la loi alors il serait paradoxal de dire
à cette femme
vous ne savez pas qui vous portez donc
vous avez droit d'avorter mais si vous
savez qui vous portez donc vous savez
que votre enfant aura une anomalie
on aurait pu leur apporter ouais c'est
pas logique bernard dans votre livre
vous parlez de tous ces problèmes là le
clonage l'eugénisme cc c'est passionnant
c'est des vrais sujets d'aujourd'hui il
ya un truc qui est très intéressant si
ce que vous appelez la paléogénétique
c'est à dire des clonages complètement
révolutionnaire cirque on arrive à faire
des mammouths aujourd'hui on va arriver
à recréer des mammouths
on va arriver à recréer peut-être
l'homme de néandertal alors
le problème est relativement ça hein
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui on fait on met
déjà deux côtés le génome des animaux
dont on sait qu'ils vont disparaître
maintenant on a trouvé vous le savez
très bien un mammouth laineux pas
parfaitement bien conservés en sibérie
dans le permafrost et on est en train
d'essayer de le faire revivre
alors c'est pas si simple parce que
l'adn n'est pas très bien classé
jurassic park et c'est ce que le
sacrement c'est exactement ce qui est
très intéressant c'est que quand on
regarde les mythes anciens gère les six
régions
on voit les chimères on voit tout ce
qu'on veut est ce que vous dites bernard
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on revient aux
chimères parce que quand on fait la
chèvre qui donne du lait avec de
mélanger deux fils d'araignée
c'est une chimère mais c'est parce que
on est en train de de faire disparaître
la barrière des espèces
la chaîne va régner l'araignée tisse de
la soie c'est formidable mais c'est un
peu difficile à récupérer parce que les
toiles d'araignées sont un peu fine donc
on va prendre le gène de l'araignée
kitty qui est responsable de la soie et
on va l'implanter dans le génome c'est à
dire dans le grand livre de la chèvre
pour que la chèvre et dans son lait des
éléments qui pourront faire de la soie
on a fait des plants de tabac qui vont
au lieu d'avoir de la sève sécréter du
sang on a fait un singe mais du jld
c'est-à-dire qu'on a pris le jeune s'est
dessinée sur l'intégrer enfin voilà
qu'elle a dit on du site absurde
oui mais mais regardez cette femme à qui
on dit vous avez un enfant malformé
parce qu'il ya un gène qui est déficient
vous avez deux choix pour l'instant soit
le garder le choix d'avorter mais avec
ce que je viens de vous dire sur les
chimères
elle a le choix de le réparer on a le
choix on aura la possibilité dans cinq
dix quinze ans
de dire madame votre enfant à le gène
qui vous donne la maladie d'alzheimer à
l'âge de 40 ans est ce que vous voulez
qu'on leur ait pas et on pourra le
réparer troisième choix dérangera un
enfant qui fait du lait je veux 4000 par
année dans ces choix là c'est avec les
marchés évoluent et là alors tout n'est
pas résolu mais c'est quand même quelque
chose d'assez extraordinaire parce qu'on
se dit c'est quand même un nouveau monde
qui arrive
oui c'est un monde où la puissance de
l'homme est telle qu'il a la possibilité
soit de se sauver soi tout détruire on
est c'est bon c'est bon pouvoir
destruction est moins belle la revanche
du serpent ou la fin
ça bien
qu aux éditions du cherche midi mais la
musique
alors en dehors de ça vous êtes député
de paris et vous allez vous présenter à
la mairie en 2008 à la wii mais oui tout
à fait pourquoi vous les jeux paraître
un peu prétentieuse je considère qu'il
faut changer les choses je considère que
ceux qui ont déjà perdu du moindre mon
camp puisque je suis à droite qui se
représentent sont pas forcément les
mieux placés pour récupérer ce qu'ils
ont fait
paris plages de nuit blanche c'est bien
non paris plages et la nuit blanche ne
me gêne pas simplement si paris est
réduit à paris plage de la nuit blanche
c'est un peu restreint donc ce que
j'aimerais c'est que paris retrouve un
peu son intérieur paris pour l'instant
c'est un peu la sous préfecture il ya
d'étrange et enfin brasse et nettoyer
ses karchériser szilasi relecture de
d'europe moi j'aimerais bien que ce soit
une vraie pour que le vrai capital
quand on est le fils de michel debré qui
a été l'auteur de la constitution de la
vème république et premiers ministres du
général de gaulle
on doit être effondrée de voir ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui à la tête de l'état
entre sarkozy et villepin non oui je
suis un peu effondré de la politique
à l'heure actuelle c'est politique c'est
très curieux parce que moi je pensais
pas que vous allez vouloir faire de la
politique après des choses énormes que
vous avez annoncé dans votre livre est
tout aimé finalement je me dis qu'on est
vraiment un des paradoxes ambulants
parce que vous annoncez des choses les
possibilités inouïes
c'est râpé l'humanité de faire des
choses extraordinaires les hommes mais
quand vous avez oublié que l'homme
n'était pas aussi évolué que ce que vous
pouvez lui amener comme technologie et
regardez là qui on donne le pouvoir on
donne des pouvoirs à des à des gens
comme bush à des gens comme sarkozy à
des gens qui vous qui pour moi
détruisent donc vous leur donnez en plus
la machine pour faire encore plus de mal
vous êtes un homme plein de paradoxes
monsieur debré et deuxièmement on donne
le pouvoir qui donne le pouvoir à qui
mais dans un cadre professionnel vous
êtes vraiment passionnant et à chaque
fois que vous êtes dans une émission
tout le monde est au garde à vous tous
vous écoute vraiment avec des avec
énormément d'intérêt je sais pas si
intéressés que l'on montre qu' il n'y
ait pas que des politiques
professionnels
non mais vous êtes effondré quand même
de voir ce qui se passe est très
attristé oui c'est ainsi loin non plus
d'intérêt national et ou là dans cette
affaire je crois que les politiques ont
une obsession c'est l'élection qui va
arriver c'est à dire trois semaines de
mois sans regarder plus loin
quels qu'ils soient de droite ou de
gauche ce que j'essaie de dire et de
dire avec mon livre aussi c'est que on a
le droit de réfléchir à ce que sera
l'homme l'humanité et dans les 10 ans 20
ans content si on fait de la politique
c'est pas pour demain matin mais j'ai
choisi un an
vous avez raison c'est bien qu'à un
moment vous serez obligé de vous définir
est ce que vous serez pour la rupture
sarkozyste ou pour la continuité
villepiniste c'est comme ça que ça se
passe et pour les gens de droite à m'en
faudra choisir entre sarkozy et villepin
voilà est-ce que vous êtes libéral ou en
libéral parce que je n'aime pas les
contraintes je n'aime pas aller loin que
ça veut dire
vous connaissez le programme de sarkozy
ça veut dire quand même que lui veut une
révolution libérale alors que ville pas
un livre que ce soit cool vous avez bien
être obligé de vous définir quel que
soit vous tout à fait tout à fait ses
dents en 2007
mais l'instant on parle de paris et là
si je suis plutôt sarkozy je le dis
j'étais avec le gouvernement c'est
quelqu'un qui a de la volonté est ce qu
il réussira j'en sais rien je suis
contre la politique un peu mollassonne
de quelqu'un qui voit là simplement de
continuer la continuité depuis la
continuité de chirac
ben écoutez je ne sais pas pour
l'instant je le crains et dites moi la
façon dont sarkozy a géré l'histoire des
banlieues là vous trouvez ça bien
je pense qu'il faut pas de tolérance
mais je pense qu'il faut pas uniquement
la répression parce que ça n'arrivera
jamais 6
de dire que dans ces banlieues il ya le
chômage
il y a des ghettos il y à un habitat qui
est épouvantable
il y à des écoles qui sont des écoles
malheureusement qui sont aussi des
ghettos je crois qu'on ne peut pas
uniquement passer par la pression parce
qu'on n'y arrivera jamais jamais jamais
jeanne nous pencher sur la façon dont
ces gérer ce trajet trouve que ces gens
on subit trop d'humiliations et que ça
c'est irrattrapable trop rarement partie
parce que je suis pas là pour prendre
d'anti je suis là pour vous écouter
mais c'est vrai quand on a un bac + 3
puces 4 + 5 qu'on s'appelle mohamed et
qu'on trouve pas de boulot ça fout bien
les glandes et après on envie de pousser
le voilà qu'on accepte les gens qui
s'appellent mohamed
saint martin
à 5 connard sud nous a roulé sur le site
l'univers kerry ouais je suis chef de
service d'un service je crois que c'est
le service qui est le plus important
d'europe
j'ai trois assistants dont un qui ne
s'appelle pas mohamed messaoudi a qui
changent d'occident 10 à écrire et qui
est un des meilleurs chirurgiens
italiens mairie venu chez moi chez truc
c'était un type bien
je lui ai demandé qu il prenne la
nationalité française il l'a prise
il est devenu mon assistant bernard il
faut qu'on arrive et on doit tous se le
dire sur ces voix là c'est plus facile à
dire qu'à faire mais il faut qu'on
arrive à ce que ces gens là qui ont fait
des études trouvent du bout même ceux
qui n'ont pas fait des tunnels ceux qui
n'ont pas fait d'études et oui mais
thierry si je n'ai pas besoin de faire
de politique
j'ai mon service il marche bien je suis
heureux ça se passe bien si j'ai envie
d'en faire c'est pour faire justement
évoluer les impatients quand on gêne de
bonsoir citoyens soient contaminés au
contact des jeunes dit espérer que mange
n2 monde citoyens contaminent les autres
interviews croyances du toit
est ce que vous croyez que l'homme
descend du singe à je suis à peu près
sûr que c'est un singe évolué est ce que
vous croyez que lagaf est le chaînon
manquant
je pense que oui
est ce que vous savez que la gauche ait
une chance en 2007 j'espère que non elle
se croyait extraterrestres les
extraterrestres oui pourquoi serions
nous seuls donc peut-être plus loin très
loin
ceci étant donné qu'en fouillant n'a pas
trouvé un moment j'ai un problème c'est
qu'ils mettaient à et le problème c'est
qu'on peut fouiller dans la banlieue
marseille maamar ceux venus et encore et
à quelques millions d'années lumière on
peut pas fouiller années pourquoi pas
est ce que vous croyez au paradis
je sais pas je suis pas sûr que les
portes ne sont ouvertes non modeste non
non je vous me dire ça t'as raison vaut
mieux jouer profil bas patrouillent à
une bouteille est ce que vous croyez
qu'un jour vous serez maire de paris
j'espère bien est ce que vous croyez que
l'homme est un loup pour l'homme
oui est ce que vous croyez qu'il faut
interdire les mariages gays le monde
mariage me choque un peu qu'ils vivent
ensemble ça me choque pas est ce que
vous croyez que le cannabis doit être
légalisée en freinant tout simplement
tout simplement parce que c'est la
première marche vers quelque chose qui
est épouvantable et je le dis et thierry
vous le savez parfaitement bien
j'ai un frère qui est reconnais votre
frère dé ce qui est un homme
parfaitement intelligent s'appelle
françois qui a écrit des livres marca
tout à fait vrai et qui a à sa vie qui a
été bouffé par la drogue sait mais c'est
le cannabis qu'il en est là où ils sont
déjà à leur propre jeu c'est plutôt
l'hérault quand même soyons numéro après
oui mais non il ya plein de gens qui
fument 99% des gens qui fument du
cannabis qui n'est pas que vous en fumée
mais ces gens là ne vont pas forcément
non c'est vrai mais l'alcool le tabac et
ses thermes a pas tout interdire
ce qui est marrant c'est qu'on
m'interdit pas ce qui fait plaisir aux
viticulteurs français emilie est atteint
de sclérose en plaques
c'est la seule chose qui lui est
conseillé recommandé par les médecins
sur cannabis mais bien sûr j'ai un ami
qui apparaît sclérose dans la salle très
qu'elle se lâche et le cannabis
est ce que vous croyez que ça va
s'arranger au moyen-orient je l'espère
je pense qu'il ya eu quelques pas qui ce
ski sont pas mauvais mais je suis assez
triste et même révolté de ce que j'ai
entendu quand le président iranien
ça alors là ça ça m'a écoeuré
pourquoi qu'il faut bombarder l'iran
avant que l'iran nous bombarde
bon je n'ai pas jusque là mais je pense
qu'il faut faire attention à ce qu'elle
n'est pas la bombe atomique
nous croyons votre prochain quand on est
chirurgien on pense que tous les hommes
sont un peu son prochain on est là pour
ça c'est l'humanisme croyant vous oui
sont bien sûr de voir surtout les
logiciels
il à meyzieu
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant l'arrivée
je
toutefois la victoire
j'accueille clovis cornillac alice
taglioni
et
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et de centraide aux 1 a
vraiment hâte à bellegarde rappelle que
harper comme un sac était mieux cp
cuisse et ferme
alors vous êtes ici tous les deux pour
les chevaliers du ciel de gérard pirès
avec vous donc benoît magimel géraldine
paillage philippe torreton en salles le
9 novembre 2005 voilà alors évidemment
au départ c'est là la bd de charlier et
uderzo qui était dans le premier numéro
de pilote en 1959 en 67 nous rappellera
des souvenirs à nous en tous les cas
c'est la série télé avec jacques senti
dans le rôle de tanguy et christian
marin dans le rôle de la verdure et
aujourd'hui donc ce film avec vous deux
dans le rôle des deux pilotes
c'est assez bien trouvé c'est assez bien
assemblé le héros un peu secret magimel
et petite moustache et puis corps n'y a
que le bon copain sympa un peu grande
gueule alors le pitch
ça commence salon aéronautique de
farnborough
alors il ya un mirage 2000 qui disparaît
en pleine démonstration la france vous
envoie tous les deux à la recherche de
ce mirage 2000 qui a disparu vous le
trouvez chez qui bat il le ton n'empêche
ils le trouvent dissimulé non vers
l'avion ses plans qu'ils arrivent sous
un airbus a340
le mirage que vous recherchez se met en
position de combat
à ce moment là vous recevez l'ordre tous
les deux magimel et vous d'abandonner le
combat mais trop tard le mirage va vous
abattre vous et magimel le descend pour
vous protéger voilà et c'est la merde et
c'est la merde parce qu'ils ont quand
même détruit un mirage 2000 avec un
pilote dedans alors qu'ils avaient ordre
de ne pas le faire à part et à ce moment
là l'état incarné par géraldine
paillasse qui bosse à matignon et
l'armée incarné par philippe torreton
voilà les deux vous tombe dessus
mais heureusement heureusement tout sera
la faute des terroristes les terroristes
l'ont remplacé les soviétiques dans ce
genre de film il faut bien le dire
maintenant voilà alors évidemment faut
aimer les avions 1
c'est mieux mais au moins la fiche elle
mérite de ne pas mentir
ouais alors contrairement au film de
christian carion dont je parlais la
semaine des as
r qui raconte la fraternisation des
soldats français et allemands écossais
en 14 juillet noël dans les tranchées
eux ils n'ont pas eu le soutien de
l'armée
vous vous lavez faisait sur ben ça c'est
évident j'entends dans le dans la phrase
genre c'est un film pro militari j'ai
bien entendu tu peux pas faire un film
aujourd'hui avec des murales je voudrais
tout comme ça ne peut pas faire un film
s'il n'ya pas l'armée parce que l'on
connaît pas de particuliers qui est
quatre mirage a dit la science ils
avaient préparé des homos clovis énorme
si je vais tomber sur des connards qui
va me reprocher car dans l'argus fils le
recrutement donc je réponds je me suis
posé la question parce qu'on est bon on
n'est pas si c'est bien l'argent on
n'est pas aidé chez les acteurs c'est
pas laquelle plus de neurones mais quand
même quand tu lis un scénario dit a
obligatoirement quand même tu dis est
bon il est le soutien de l'armée que ça
qu'est ce que ça veut dire est ce que
moi j'ai quand je d'ailleurs c'est
rigolo parce que on invitait cette
émission pour les chevaliers du ciel bim
mais quand je faisais les pièces de
guerre d'edward bond on n'était pas
invité et c'est des pièces qui mettait
en cause doit l'armée tout ça pas de
matelas dont je me dis c'est bien c'est
un peu paradoxal pour moi de me
retrouver sur un projet qui souhaitait
avec l'armée n'est enfin dassault et
dassault bien sûr
et donc c'est bien parce qu'en fait des
placements de produits hier et
fahrenheit c'est ce que je mets du
[Rires]
mais remarquez je parle pas de loup
parce que je suis très embêté il se
contenter du rôle que vous avez dans le
film si je parle de votre rôle un peu
trop c'est ça va vendre la mèche
forcément ça dépend de quoi vous parlez
ben je parle de la fin mai ah ouais on
peut parler du début aussi au début vous
êtes magnifique
voilà parce qu'elle ne regardez à quoi
ça ressemble j'ai regardé tous les deux
votre caméra c'est le cas le rouge et en
même temps vous devez dire je sais
magnéto serge khalfon attention c'est
difficile je sais 1 2 3 magnéto serge
khalfon non non c'est de la bouillie si
c'est bien dans le texte le texte vous
l'avez d'accord tous les terrains allait
il se peut sourire c'est importante
immersion s'il appuiera passionnée entre
2,3 et magnéto serge khalfon voilà pas
des noms de famille on en fait on y va
aller attention 1-2-3 même manière vous
savez quelle forme bien accueillir de
nouveau avec une petite surprise
on les faire tourner jusqu'à ce qu'ils
appellent leur merde
les patients derrière la sema loi et on
chez toi tu veux avoir une surprise
faire chouchouter par des meufs
c'est moche c'est un petit nous cherche
et le retrouver ah ça c'est si leurs
rêves
tu vois c'est pour ça que j'adore ce job
aussi on va la visite moselle costil
cabinet du premier ministre candidat les
plus vils demande pas si c'était
possible je vous dis le faire est ce que
vous voulez les deux meilleurs pilotes
de l'armée de l'air a commenté un
chercheur âge de mille possibilités
hostile
mon autorisation tir de semences
multifenêtrage moi je vous en donne
hélas pour ses compétences
j'engage
n'ai pas entendu leur forme de mon
émission cet appareil est ouvert le feu
sur mon équipier si c'est lui qui a fait
une connerie cette fois tu pourras pas
le couvrir
la commission conclut que vous avez
délibérément ignoré un autre d'abandon
de poursuites
en conséquence vous est radié du corps
des officiers de l'air
moi j'aime ça
avant même de marcher j'avais volé
j'ai une mission sauver de renseignement
ceignant la prison de salé de terrorisme
ils nous ont détourné un mirage 2000
bâlois et vous avec les pilotes dans
cette mission un peu sans ces noms
viendront parce que le seul endroit au
moment où leur confiera un jet à piloter
ce sera chez moi
paris-sg haute protection
bien sûr je me rattrape intercepté
le milieu rap à leicester
il ya des gens à l'intérieur
voilà les chevaliers du ciel de gérard
pirès sortie et main
et saluer quand maman moi j'ai lu ici
c'est très très très bien réalisé vous
êtes très sympa tous les deux la même
impression de mac ça m'a donné très
sincèrement quand j'ai vu la fiche avant
de voir le film j'ai eu super peur j'ai
vu la fille je me suis c'est un tout
petit peu prétentieux est-ce que ça
répond à la salle réellement alors sur
le jeu je serai le dernier à pouvoir
dire si c'est bien ou pas en revanche je
me dis oui ça assure du côté aviation
tout ça mais franchement ça rassure
alors qu'aux visites vous allez rester
dans l'adaptation de série télé avec les
brigades du tigre qui va sortir bientôt
et puis l'adaptation d'astérix vous
allez remplacer christian clavier
oui je n'ai pas peur de vous retrouver
dans maggie le film non mais dans
l'homme du picardie
il ya un gros projet de film d'aventurés
malabar princess mensonges et trahisons
un long dimanche de fiançailles brice de
nice
vous êtes passé du statut d'acteur au
statut de banque est bonne
maintenant vous êtes quelqu'un sur qui
on peut monter un projet est passé de
2,2 scénario par mois à cinq par semaine
c'est bien non c'est non c'est très bien
mais doute une manière d'être enfin de
manière générale pour n'importe qui
d'être jeu pas plébiscité dans son
travail vous désirez c'est vachement
agréable c'est très flatteur mais je ne
suis pas naïf je sais bien que c'est en
ce moment c'est vrai vous êtes en ait
six vous allez bosser parce que vous
êtes partis de chez vous à l'âge de 14
ans j'ai commencé à bosser à 15 enfin
gea ce n'est pas un poulet de l'année
savez quand même quelques anecdotes sur
le marché quoi oui ça qui est bien c'est
que traite en pression ni à bail il
vient d'arriver mais non ça fait un
moment alors c'est besnehard qui vous
accusent qui vous a découvert un jour
ils vous ont envoyé voir peter brook aux
bouffes du nord
et vous croyez que c'est mel brooks vous
c'est vrai ça c'est vrai j'ai pas
toujours été aussi fin que maintenant
ea et brooke bon je me suis à génial
c'est super puis je suis arrivé
ouais tu arrivé à la chapelle enfin on
est trop la chapelle et tout à coup je
me suis dit tiens c'est bizarre quand
même avec des potes à la chapelle de
byzance et puis on arrive dans le
théâtre des bouffes du nord ni au la
nasa des clochards ça a brûlé
ça faisait j'étais complètement j'avais
un regard mais inverse quand vous étiez
petit vous détestiez ce métier beaux
parents étaient dans le métier myriam
boyer roger cornillac metteur en scène
n'hésitez pas des vedettes en fait il
était un peu d comme des intermittents
d'une certaine façon c'était des gens
qui ne faillit pas énormément et vous
n'aviez pas envie de faire ce boulot
vouliez deux boxeurs j'étais j'ai rêvé
de ça mais j'ai un homme plein de gamins
rêve à moi j'ai pas être offert une mais
j'étais mauvais donc la chance que j'ai
eue sainement en compte assez tôt donc
j'ai perdu un peu de neurones mais juste
voilà ça s'est arrêté pile poil un rôle
de flic
ah oui exact alors ça chapeau alors
chapeau et la fin dites moi comment tu
sais ça me fait plaisir c'est ça qui
m'étonne qu'il qui commet comment tu
sais ça comment tu sais ça très bien bas
voilà c'est ma récompense
as tu réponds pas abattoir
il suffit qu en dise comment si c'est le
cas c'est un peu de plaisir à le
renverser
voilà en tous les cas vous avez fait
beaucoup de théâtre avant de percer au
cinéma mais vous avez été extrêmement
courageux vous dites j'ai l'âme
prolétaires et ouvrière chez nous on
bosse quoi oui par proches
non mais enfin c'est vrai que quand tu
entends des choses que tu as dit dans la
bouche de quelqu'un d'autre il dit c'est
ridicule je vais lui dire ça comme ça
est ce que je veux dire c'est que oui on
vient d'un milieu qui est ce milieu là
voire même d'un côté vraiment le sous
prolétariat et j'ai toujours vu ma grand
mère est sa me parler parce qu elle me
gardait souvent je pense à m souvent et
il y avait quelque chose sur sur la
valeur du travail quoi mais mais bon ça
m'ennuie de le dire comme ça parce que
des fois il faut j'entends des gens que
j'aime pas du tout parlé comme ça donc
je voudrais pas que ça fasse un amalgame
c'est juste et d'avoir la chance de
faire un boulot comme ça quand tu lé m
alors qu'il y en a moins joué amado
remet à chacun non chier tout le relais
voilà je tous les jours c'est vrai qu'on
me dit souvent tu enchaînes les filles
mais que ça mais avant j'ai enchaîné les
pièces de théâtre jeter pour moi c'est
normal de me lever le matin dans l état
fait c'est un pays c'est oui quand
j'avais cinq piges par exemple j'allais
à l'école en bus et je me souviens avant
tu sais ça mais c'est dingue cette
question
sincèrement en fait j'avais le le trio
dire le chauffeur de bus il est libre
ouais le mec qui bosse
j'avais qu'une envie c'est d'être adulte
pour travailler pour être que comme le
chauffeur de bus allaient boire mon
canon avec les collègues au café yé pas
être à l'école enfermé avec des gens que
j'aime bien ça alors ça marche bien pour
vous aussi alice mans ça va ça va au
départ vous c'était plutôt la musique
j'ai fait du piano depuis l'âge de 4 ans
jusqu'à l'âge de 19 20 ans à 20 ans vous
étiez un peu comme ça un peu attardé
vous aviez envie de rien il est petit
boulot comme ça un peu plus entré dans
un cours de théâtre
et puis voilà quoi une directrice de
casting vos remarques et tout va très
vite c'est miraculeux aussi on peut dire
ça beaucoup de chance et j'aime bien
enfin souvent que le vix se dit
il a de la chance de faire ce métier que
c'est beaucoup de chance mais parce que
j'aime bien dans ton discours c'est
qu'on sent que c'est un bosseur aussi
c'est pas juste les choses tombent
dessus comme ça par hasard il ya un vrai
moi je le vois clovis ça fait trois
films qu'on enchaîne ensemble je vois
comment il travaille comme un malade
c'est un boulot de dingue ce qui fait
moi je fais pas le quart de sa et
il oublie de le dire mais c'est moi
j'adore en regarder fusion s'était fait
l'ouest mais j'apprends regardons de
gens comme ça j'attends c'est un vrai
boulot et c'est pas facile mais on a
fait une lecture moi j'ai vu un mec
avait bossé et fit enfin ceux qui
n'avaient pas mais en même temps c'est
une autre façon j'aime bien être sur un
fil se planter certes mais remontée du
marché - ouali se dit même si vous êtes
trop grande trop blonde trop belle il ya
un retour quand même du glamour ce que
moi vous incarnez un peu ça non parce
que je voulais quand je vois les
chevaliers du ciel je trouve que ce film
est glamour si je trouve que en revient
à des films de héros et c'est pas plus
mal ça fait du bien ri en france c'est
très bien le cinéma français moi j'aime
beaucoup je suis très fan je vais
souvent voir des films français cinéma
d'auteur ou comédie favorable c'est très
bien aussi qu'on est aussi nos héros nos
goûts nos beaux gosses nobel fille et
que de représenter quelque chose de
glamour mystique et
une beauté mais en même temps je suis
sûr que tu peux tu as rangé pour être
plus normal alors non mais vous dites
aussi alice que c'est parfois difficile
vous dit quand il faut être prêt à 6h
pour tourner ben faut se lever à 4h30 du
matin quoi c'est pas c'est pas
obligatoirement drôle faut pleurer sur
commande à vous avez du mal à pleurer
sur commande à cette histoire belge n
explique heures au fond il a pensé à sa
grand mère chacun fait penser à quoi
qu'on voulait pleurer vous je pense à
rien je pense à pleurer elle pense à la
scène ouais je pense que le mieux c'est
de ressentir le truc ne sais pas je ne
sais pas bon j'avais le pleure on va
apprendre à wimereux quelques fois
beaucoup plus difficile de rire fou rire
dans les arbres il a fallu faire sortir
tout le monde
oui ce que je pleurais mais pour rire
bon quand vous êtes deux acteurs on va
faire une interview un acteur sur deux
un deux trois
bon attention un acteur sur deux fait
croire qu'il a fait le cours florent
parmi vous c'est lequel aucun avec un
solde se lance dans la chanson parmi
vous c'est lequel à cesseras mois attend
une fin de saison pleine de faire de la
musique mais j'ai pas et j'ai pas
quitter mes amours d'enfance mais un
acteur sur deux lycées scénario en une
nuit avant de dire banco aux
réalisateurs parmi vous c'est le calme
oui je lis oui en général une qu'une
seule fois un scénario et d'un coup donc
ça peut être un soir effectivement un
petit ennui messager un plot douala dans
le monde me dit pourquoi tu fais ça mais
j'ai trop de respect pour les gens qui
écrivent et je vois des trucs et je
voyais du loup qui va jusqu'au bout pour
voir le jour ça va non parce que je me
dise on bossait quoi un acteur sur deux
a été pistonné par ses parents par mais
vous c'est lequel ah non un acteur sur
deux finit par jouer un rôle dont il a
honte par mais vous c'est lequel non et
pourtant j'en ai fait des supers pas
bien un acteur sur deux ne s'est pas
joué un joli cul parmi vous c'est le cas
chez un acteur sur deux qu'alcoolique
parmi vous c'est lequel
enfin je bats amène moi je n'en ai que
le ter sur 2 promena coq parmi vous
c'est lequel l'acteur sur deux fait ce
métier pour les filles parmi vous c'est
lequel
un acteur sur deux doit tout à son
physique parmi vous et lequel histoire
c'est moi un acteur / de rêve dans un
rôle de flic les jeudis soir sur tf1
parmi vous c'est lequel moi j'ai fait
france 2 déjà on est un acteur sur deux
a posé nue un jour parmi vous c'est
lequel a pas posé nue toi parce que tu
attends ben j'attends qu'on me propose
bah oui alors demain gérard il faudrait
un acteur sur deux se la pète à mort
parmi vous c'est lequel je vais dire moi
parce que j'ai mal ter sur 2 avec gross
a un parmi vous c'est lequel un acteur
sur deux envie de se toucher les seins
maintenant mais c'est vraiment pour toi
la bande originale déchets solides
de toi
[Musique]
c'est moi ou c'est clovis et tous les
deux pour toi une pour lui après carte
est riche vous gagner le droit de regard
des 10 secondes les réponses au blind
test assez cool
ouais on peut avoir les réponses de la
vitesse je lui montrais une autre pour
clovis cartes jeux et les vieux vous
devez dire du mal de l'abbé pierre
pendant que tu cherches que tu vas bien
au sujet de l'abbé pierre je les montre
et des réponses du blind et la sadc
paludisme papables derrière ça ça va pas
née quel jeu de tous
ok bon alors abbé-pierre ça arrive la
corne irak il a il n'a pas voulu coucher
avec moi et ben j'ai pas fait partie de
ses premiers choix et ça je peux dire
que je m'en veux beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
je vais
problème qu'est ce tu vas gagner la
horde qui viennent alors
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
et vous
live your life et celle ordinaire celle
sur le sample son nom simple bien
toujours un morceau de toile jada
m
voilà tu as chanté à côté moi je suis
allé faire des puissances ont alors été
lancées durant magnifique
ah ouais mais tu vas venir bientôt ici
tu viens 114 voix pour lui on ne rigole
pas avec lui cegedim la porte a coûté
que scarlett dans un film de mel brooks
un jeu chez nous ça s'est passé comment
avec durant la pertinence à huawei à
doha 14 devant le nouveau et c'est ce
que j'ai réussi à le gêner j'ai chanté
un peu d'un petit bout de cello sky de
lennon devant franz ferdinand et alors
et alors c'était ridicule
mon album ouais bah oui bien pour en
parler là je passais g1 apportée par
exemplaire aujourd'hui oui c'est bien
moi tu vas rester pour le blind test
ce qu'on va faire d'abord je vais dire
au revoir à madame mademoiselle moreau
assise co2 ainsi qu'aux de depardieu
robert et tulle à boire un coup avec
depardieu
quand ils émissions et tu reviens bonne
blague d'accord là dessus de viège
et
m
[Musique]
je ne sais pas
m
mais les rois maudits donc il ya c'est
lundi soir à 21 h 50 sur france 2 et
encore mardi soir voilà
vous cliquez là lille bouquin c'est
mortel vous mais moi je suis une
électrice pour bernard debré un lecteur
une lectrice soit payé lui-même entre
lecteurs et lectrices de convertir les
leaders de bord et la musique mon cul là
elle sort sans musique elle
j'accueille nathalie et andré kaas
alors vous êtes les héros d'une
incroyable histoire au départ andré kaas
vous êtes promoteur immobilier à qui
tout réussit vous vivez avec votre femme
sylviane et vos enfants dont nathalie
dans une magnifique demeure
vous aimez sylviane et elle vous aime
d'un amour fou et le 5 avril 1992 alors
que vous êtes au cinéma avec vos enfants
sylviane est sauvagement assassiné alors
très vite on tient une piste mais on
l'abandonnent et 18 mois plus tard andré
vous êtes nés en prison pour avoir
commandité le meurtre de votre épouse
depuis en prison
sur dénonciation voilà vous fait trois
ans de prison 9 ans sous contrôle
judiciaire
évidemment ruines de vos affaires ruines
de votre famille cinq enfants dont vous
nathalie à l'abandon et le non lieu est
finalement prononcée le 26 mars 2004
mais vous demander réparation vous
demandez qu'on juge le véritable
assassin de votre femme alors tout ceci
vous le raconter dans un livre qui est
publié chez michel lafon qui s'appelle
pas de pitié pour les innocents voilà là
on va reprendre la faire dès le début on
va voir ce qui vous est arrivé
sylviane originaire du nord vous
originaire du maroc
votre famille vient en france à la fin
du protectorat français en 58 quand vous
vous rencontrez avec sylviane vous
n'avez pas encore 18 ans et vous
réalisez c'est assez étonnant d'ailleurs
le jour où sylviane vous amène chez elle
vous reconnaissez l'appartement et vous
vous réalisez que vous êtes taper sa
mère au même endroit alors dès le début
avec sylvia nous avait une une vie
sexuelle s'est débridé vous avez passé
des week-ends en hollande amsterdam
voilà elle était jolie sylviane un
ravissant elle ressemblait à mérida
alors sans la mairie d'arqués puis je
les connais à 17 ans elle a eu le
courage de me supporter pendant 23 ans
et lui fallait beaucoup de talent pour
ça alors rapidement s'ils viennent est
enceinte de vous nathalie
vous cherchez quelqu'un pour avorter
vous trouvez pas et finalement quand on
voit votre fille on est content vous
ayez trouvé personne pour apporter
sylviane oui moi aussi mais à 19 ans
elle est née j'avais 19 ans et deux
jours on n'était pas vraiment préparé
mais chez absolument ravi qu'on ait
trouvé personne
alors vous êtes assez volage faut le
dire quoi oui je l'étais on peut
conjuguer à l'imparfait
ouais wee cc c'est tout ça en fait qui
amène la lutte armée
les présentations qui pèse sur vous
parce qu'un jour s'il vient et chez le
coiffeur et elle entend vos copines qui
raconte vos exploits sexuels avec elle
donc ça ça crée des crises évidemment
avec sylviane oui puis on était très
jeune c'était en 72 donc c'est la seule
séparation que nous aurons c'est une
séparation qui va durer quelques mois
voilà et ensuite tout peut repartir
tranquillement elle revient vous vous
mariez voilà et parallèlement vous
réussissez très bien dans vos affaires
vous vendez les maisons voilà et ça se
passe tellement bien vous finissez par
vous installer à rouen dans une superbe
chaumières normande
alors vous êtes d amant fougueux mais
infi d'alain faut dire infidélités
chroniques alors vous trouver une
solution pour régler vos problèmes avec
sylviane c'est l'échangisme
c'est une très belle époque vous avez de
plus de cléopâtre oui noter chez les
amateurs
maintenant d'autres il suspend veut dire
en tous les cas c'est que le libertinage
vous aide à rester ensemble quoi ça
résout le problème
disons que c'est une façon de cohabiter
et surtout lorsqu on s'est connus parce
qu'elle savait tout de moi et je savais
tout d'elle quand on s'est mariés
puisque nous sommes connus à l'âge de 17
ans et on s'est marié en avait
deux ans bien qu on avait eu le temps de
vraiment se connaître par contre je
dérape par nathalie qui avait de temps
en temps de vagues confidences de sa
mère ses frères il n'y aurait tout notre
vie on avait davantage de beaucoup
voyager donc bon et cette affaire
comment dire a malheureusement fait que
des parents au moment de l'assassinât de
votre femme c'est sûr que tout est
remonté je vais pas commencer à dire oui
mais enfin il était échangiste tout ça
donc il y avait quand même ça ça crée
des doutes à l'époque alors ensuite vous
est pris par la folie des grandeurs fait
construire une maison de 700 m² avec
dorures marbre salles de cinéma salle de
jeu celle de billard piscine sonore
toilettes une erreur de l'architecte
aucun jeune enfant tout le temps voilà
un peu la folie des grandeurs alors
votre femme se lance dans les affaires
mais ça se passe pas très bien parce
qu'à une époque où vous vous êtes à plus
3,5 millions d'euros elle est à -3 5
millions d'euros elle m'a supporté
pendant à peu près 17 ans et
professionnellement elle s'est mis à
travailler avec moi et donc l appliquer
généralement les mêmes méthodes et 4,5
en avant la fin de sa vie
malheureusement elle a décidé de prendre
des chemins qui lui était personnelle et
ça lui a bien réussi au départ et
ensuite ça s'est retourné et donc qu'on
était dans deux situations qui étaient
diamétralement opposées mais je dirais
que rien au niveau de notre vie ou laver
les enfants d'aller changer ça on avait
les mêmes employés la même chose je
dirais qu'il y avait toujours un des
deux qui étaient là pour compenser pour
l'autre puisqu'on avait eu
l'intelligence alors qu'on était fauché
quand on s'est mariés de se marier sous
le régime de la séparation des biens
donc chacun avait quand je dis ça parce
que c'est important pour la suite
évidemment pour l'anc est voilà
l'échangisme votre femme qui a des
problèmes d'argent tout ça c'est énorme
on brosse le tableau de l'anc est alors
le dimanche 5 avril 1992
toute la famille décide d'aller voir le
film de spielberg ou qu au cinéma à
rouen
votre femme sylviane et fatiguée elle
décide de paille aller et le soir à 19
heures quand vous revenez
sa bmw n'est pas là sylviane a été
assassiné trois balles dans la poitrine
et on la retrouve avec votre ville chez
ce terre sur le ventre voilà alors les
soupçons se portent directement sur un
délinquant notoire mais finalement c'est
classé comme affaires non résolues
absolument à ce moment là elle est non
résolus il rien ne se passera pendant à
peu près 18 mois voilà alors vous vous
êtes un peu le veuf joyeux à dire que
votre maîtresse martin vient à la maison
sitôt votre femme enterrée et elle mais
même les vêtements de votre femme
sylviane ce qui provoque votre colère
nathalie non si vous voulez le veuf je
savais pas trop de risques en général
ils papillonnent est pas mal mais la
gare d'europe ça j'avais envie et puis
le 8 novembre 1993 donc dit flics
débarquent chez vous on vous soupçonne
du meurtre de votre femme
on tape à la porte on me dit
on vient perquisitionné j'ai une dizaine
de policiers du service des stupéfiants
pourquoi les stupéfiants bien parce que
c'est un inspecteur des stupéfiants qui
a recueilli les déclarations d'un dealer
qui arrêté à la frontière à des
confessions à faire pour amoindrir sa
peine et il va donc dénoncer les auteurs
de deux meurtres
l'un d'un douanier à grand-quevilly dont
on n'aura jamais d'ailleurs arrêté le
coupable puisque on ne sait toujours pas
qui l'a tué bien qu'on ait eu la photo
du type pendant le meurtre et l'autre
c'est moi
alors heureusement les gens dénoncé pour
le meurtrier du douanier avait des
empreintes digitales du sang et tout
donc la scientifique mans ils sont
sortis d'affaires rapidement mais dans
son rapport le policier disait que c'est
pas parce qu'ils s'étaient trompés pour
l'autre qu'il avait menti qu'il avait
forcément menti pour moi alors quand les
flics débarquent à la maison et arrêtent
votre père pour le meurtre de votre mère
vous réagissez comment vous nathalie
qu'à cette époque shalit est à paris
donc on m'a demandé de revenir la police
nous a m'a téléphoné en me disant
écoutez on a des bijoux à trouver des
bijoux éventuellement ce que vous
pourriez venir les reconnaître je suis
venu sans savoir que toute la famille
avaient été arrêtés et interrogés
et là on m'a dit bon on vous met en
garde à vue jeudi bon c'est dommage
parce que j'étais habillée très
légèrement je sortais d'un théâtre
si j'avais su j'aurais pris des
chaussettes et j'ai écouté
divagation des policiers pendant des
heures et puis je suis sorti le
lendemain mon père est resté
hélas ce qui est incroyable c'est les
témoignages à charge je crois c c'est à
dire que votre belle mère la mère de
sylviane témoigne contre vous martin la
fameuse martin témoigne d'entre vous
c'est l'enfer ça sert qu'à ce moment là
il vous trouve des raisons pratiquement
d'avoir commis ce meurtre
c'est à dire qu appartement on vous
reproche quelque chose pour lequel vous
êtes coupable
bon à la limite je dirais presque la
défense est facile parce que vous avez
fait quelque chose ou pas vous savez
donc vous pouvez discuter mais si on
vous reproche un truc totalement absurde
là c'est difficile parce que vous ne
sais pas d'où ça tombe et en plus la
discussion est absurde alors qu'on me
reproche un héritage
il faut savoir que on refusera le sien
on me reproche un contrat d'assurance
qui n'est pas à moi j'étais devenu
comment dire un type absolument
abominable et là d'un seul coup je
comprends pas et le juge
ces quatre ces témoignages on a un juge
aussi qui est comment dire qu'il a tout
résumé le juge récemment il a déclaré il
ya quelques semaines il y avait 18 mois
de rumeurs et on peut dire une pré
vérités judiciaires établis
c'est ce qu'il a dit bon on suit ça
c'est quand la vérité quand la vérité et
et énoncées avant l' enquête alors ce
qui est terrible c'est que vos jeunes
enfants qui à l'époque en 15 et 13 ans
les filles vont les chercher à l'école
quoi je sais c'est horrible et puis
cette policière qui dit ça y est on
tient devant juifs quoi oui c'est à dire
qu'il ya il ya deux choses comptent
jouer contre vous il ya les montres
histoire d'échangisme de deux mecs un
peu volage et puis un antisémitisme
provincial aujourd'hui encore en 2005
les déclarations de l'avocat jean-pierre
du trésor quand la bride jolis trésors
essaye d'expliquer pourquoi c'était au
fond normal qu'on m'arrête
il met qu'un seul document du dossier
sur ce document il ya la déclaration du
dealer il ya 18 lignes sur 18 à cinq
fois le mot juif il ya bien autre chose
sur 18 ça c'est en 2005
aujourd'hui et c'est quelqu'un qui
représente l'état qui prend ce seul
document est en lutte en 2005
ouais vous allez en prison et en prison
vous souffrez de l'antisémitisme
évidemment vous
vrai des problèmes sexuels disons qu'ils
peuvent se passer la drogue vous dites
que vous ai jamais vu autant de bruit
quand qu'en prison la prison c'est la
société extérieure
si vous êtes fort physiquement et
psychologiquement ça se passe bien
si vous êtes faible psychologiquement et
physiquement c'est affreux l'inégalité
est encore plus terrible
si vous aviez le voir à l'époque on
présente
oui tout laissant plusieurs semaines
bonne fille oui non mais c'est surtout
que je lui donne enfin je vous rendez
compte par rapport à l'éducation des
enfants s'expliquer il ya pas eu d
assistance sociale sur les jeunes
enfants mais j'annonce un délitement
complet de votre famille oui j'en ai 22
ans à l'époque
donc mon petit frère que j'avais deux
adolescents et un tout petit donc
c'était c'était ce n'est pas facile tout
seul vous avez signé l'appel des 200
l'an nouvel observateur j'ai vu un oui
absolument justin appel des deux sens
parce que je suis très concerné sur
l'amélioration des conditions faites aux
prisonniers et je dirais que c'est
inhumain
je dirais de que des gens qui n'ont pas
d'argent ne puissent pas acheter un rôle
papier hygiénique ne puisse pas se
nourrir
des faits que dans une cellule de vent
lors de copains ou trois copains c'est
réduire l'être humain est inutilement
humiliante et inutilement humiliant vous
êtes mis à poil en permanence alors à ce
moment là on vous accuse d'avoir tué
votre femme pour toucher l'assurance vie
est de 5 millions alors qu'en fait elle
avait 26 millions de francs de dettes
est comme une petite histoire et
toujours ce qui est un peu compliqué
quand même avec vous c'est sur des
petits trucs il ya quand même 2 7
millions de francs vais toucher des des
agf s'était pas votre dû vous n'aviez
pas vraiment rendu quoi oui c'est à dire
que le crédit foncier commandé à mon
épouse devaient 5 millions 4 crédit
foncier elle avait sa mine assurances
donc lavées - assurance qui est qu'elle
n'avait de dettes et l'assureur pour des
raisons qu'il était très personnelle m'a
fait virer une partie de cet argent le
crédit foncier m'a dit ren moi ça et on
a trouvé un accord la preuve en est
c'est que je viens de refaire ma
première grosse opération immobilière à
hirson dans l'aisne et c'est le crédit
foncier bien kim à financer alors voilà
donc à ce moment là la famille explose
toutes vos affaires sont bradés vaut
bien vos propriétés et puis ça sort le
scandale sort c'est vous apprenez à ce
moment là que votre mère était disant
libertines moi personnellement je savais
que mon père avait
et des liaisons extérieures et je ne
pensais pas que ma mère en avait je suis
bien contente qu'elle ait eu bon bah
écoutez je moi je évidemment quand elle
me disait ton père ce jeudi mais prend
un amant ça me semblait tout à fait
logique
oui quand vous apprenez le 2 plusieurs
clés au coffret tout ça vous choque pas
du tout d'accord voilà enfin tous les
cas il ya de deux enfants à la ramasse
les deux les deux plus jeunes pour
qu'ils soient pas dû être très facile et
il faudra attendre le 26 mars 2004 pour
vous bénéficiez d'un an lieux et
l'indemnité qu'on vous a donné
finalement en comparaison de tout ce que
ça vous a coûté cette erreur judiciaire
elle est minime quand vous donne 70000
euros d'indemnités par rapport à tout ce
que vous avez perdu c'est rien du tout
moi je suis incapable d'évaluer mais
j'ai pris le meilleur expert judiciaire
comptable de la place de roncq et expert
en mission pour les tribunaux qui est
enfin connu un cabinet normes il estimé
sa plus de 300 euros
pourquoi et quand on va retrouver
l'assassin de votre femme un de ces
jours et je dirais qu'aujourd'hui il
existe des tests adn il existe des
éléments techniques qui je l'espère si
tous les échantillons n'ont pas été
gâchée peut-être nous permettrait
d'avoir une vérité que pour l'instant
nous n'avons pas en attendant on
soupçonne quelqu'un qui a agressé plein
de femmes et dont le modus operandi est
toujours le même
bon manifestement on aurait pu aller
voir cette piste dans les 48 heures d'un
compte twitter du meurtre alors on
aurait su s'il était coupable ou pas à
ce moment là mais ça aurait peut-être
évité tout ce cauchemar qu'on a connu
moi ce qui est grave dans cette affaire
c'est pas tellement moi c'est surtout
les enfants parce que moi je suis né
pauvre donc je me suis fabriqué tout
seul là je recommence essart fonctionne
pas trop mal mais par contre mes enfants
eux sont nés comme des gosses de riches
avec tout ce que la vie offre un emploi
une maison jardin vacances n'importe où
pas de budget fin on vie quoi et d'un
seul coup ils sont passés de comment
dire de taillevent et la serre ils sont
passés à aller une fois de temps en
temps au flunch pas donc en gros c'est
ça schématiquement de la cafétéria et
donc ça a été pour eux très difficile
parce que ils ont perdu ce qui n'aurait
jamais dû perdre
après leur mère ils ont perdu leurs
peurs et ensuite ils ont perdu leur vie
sociale tôt et leur chance d'étudier
leurs chances de continuer à 21 ans elle
avait sa maîtrise de droit donc elle
était très très brillante et elle a vu
ce qu'était la justice a le plus envie
de faire du droit à quoi
je voulais être magistrate justement
c'est pour ça que je faisais de droit et
quand j'ai voulu m'inscrire au concours
de la magistrature on expliquer
gentiment que avec un papa en présence
n'était pas la peine et dans votre
parcours judiciaire vous avez rencontré
des magistrats vous aviez déjà croisé en
boîte échangiste ou quoi de dos merci
merci
est ce lui
tous les bateaux tous les oiseaux tous
les soleils arismore tout l'hérault
bus toutes les choses qui te merwe
l'enlisement petite fille de ma rue
j'accueille michel et fanny le headband
[Applaudissements]
le
tous les bateaux tous les oiseaux tous
les soleils toutes les roses toutes les
choses qui s'émerveillent voilà tous les
bateaux tous les oiseaux s'est extrait
d'un cd intitulé je te donnerai ou fait
des duos michel leeb avec mathilde
seigner sur les divorcées avec evelyne
bouix sur est maintenant avec caroline
cellier sur les vieux amants et
christina reali sur la belle vie voilà
il ya aussi un duo avec marc lavoine et
gérard darmon sur une chanson qu'on
adore qui s'appelle alors raconte voilà
on a eu l'idée de faire ça avec avec six
femmes voilà dont une que je connais
depuis elle est louée cette famille là
les musiciens et chanteuses sa soeur
elsa elle c'est plutôt la comédie il a
été remarqué par lellouche comme votre
fils 14 ans il a joué avec vous dans
madame doubtfire et ça va ça oui pas mal
je vais pouvoir m'arrêter de travailler
bien ce qu'ils font leurs heures ils
font alors on va regarder le pk c'est ce
que si le pk électronique press kit
voilà qui contrairement au clip n'est
pas exigée par orlando qui sont donc on
va il s'en fout orlando lille ep caïman
fu c'est pas obligé donc qui n'exige pas
le pk vous en faites ce que vous devez
faire quand même c'est regarder votre
caméra tous les deux là et dire magnéto
serge attention les enfants
magnéto serge
[Musique]
de tous les maux
teulet chose quitter même
petite nuit
je te donnerai
m
l'ec l'ol
les fruits d'or
il est au trésor
en bas sur les hutois
pleure pas
là
pana
ajoute que gunner
il serait bien l'album bonne chanson bon
choix
vous arrivez du théâtre là ouais comment
ça se passe très bien
succès non sam amitié sincère edouard
cette mise en scène de bernard murat qui
joue d'ailleurs aussi sur scène alors le
pic ces deux vieux amis qui attendent un
troisième ami ils apprennent qu'il est
mort et qu'il a sauté sa fille en ce qui
vous concerne
oui voilà et donc c'est un peu le
problème que peut poser
l'intervention l'intrusion d'une femme
dans la vie de trois amis qui se
connaissent depuis toujours et quand
cette femme et ma fille c'est encore
plus compliqué ouais voilà mais aucune
aucunement
non mais vous sérieusement ça vous si
vous saviez qu'elle se tape un mec de 50
balais ça vous emmerde vrai ça me
poserait un problème probablement oui
j'suis pas ça dépend qui je crois que
c'est pas vraiment lui dire je ne sens
pas prête on perd à partir de quel âge
ça vous inquiète c'est à dire 20 ans pas
de problème je sais pas et je crois que
l'important c'est qu'elle les fait
comment elles soient elles soient
heureuses mais se pose non sérieusement
les problèmes se poseront un jour ou
l'autre ça finira probablement mal les
attirée par les hommes mûrs tu veux je
leur pose la question d'un sauvetage
alors vous toute façon vous risquez rien
parce qu'il n'est pas question michel de
tromper votre femme béatrice
d'abord parce que c'est la patronne a
quand même hein c'est la longue ils
portent un coup mais c'est vrai non mais
c'est vrai elle vous elle tient la
boutique qui produit oui voici voilà
c'est ça qui a produit l'album bas et où
elle produit tout la vision et le kanak
est ce les enfants pendant là les
enfants rient donc pas question de la
tromper d'abord parce que c'est la
patronne wallon faut pas se faire voler
sa sa voix ça c est chose et on appuie
aussi ce qu'il peut dire c'est que vous
avez été très marquée par la séparation
de vos parents vos oui mais enfin c'est
pas ben si vous n'avez pas envie de
[ __ ] le bordel vous avez vu ce que
c'était
oui bien sûr
et non je ne suis pas je suis pas marqué
au fer les compères la tuer non mais
financières exclues période de la vie
quand on est adolescent des parents se
séparent c'est assez difficile à vivre
bon c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui je peux
pas imaginer qu'une situation comme ça
se reproduise ne serait-ce qu
effectivement pour pour leur équilibre
bon c'est voilà ça va pas plus loin que
ça
donc je fais ce qu'il faut pour que ça
ne se passe pas mais non mais non 87
dans sexy folies quand vous avoué avoir
trompé votre femme dans sexy folies
oui en 87 dans sexy folies quand vous
avoué avoir trompé votre femme
c'était pas vrai alors non mais c'est
pour faire une émission de télévision à
d'accord je m'assurais à ouidah qu'à la
promotion
oui c'était pas vrai mais pour nous
avons besoin maintenant qu'il est
extraordinaire
oui et non parce que je me disais quand
même c'est pas possible il faudra pas
comme ça en trente ans de métier c'est
un gros con mais quand vous dites la
fidélité ça se passe dans la tête à
l'époque si je disais ça n'est pas que
j'étais beaucoup plus jeune aussi moi
mais c'était alors les choses évoluent
voilà calme un peu ouais ouais ouais
normal on arrive à un âge où on
réfléchit un peu d'attention
ouais si j'étais pas dire la même chose
on a fait sortir pour voir juste pour
confirmer
vous êtes sages alors oui très sale non
c'est bien
je félicite ces gentils en tous les cas
il ya une chose c'est que désormais vous
semblez très bien accepté par le milieu
du théâtre désormais désormais non parce
que c'est vrai que c'est difficile
d'avoir la carte vous savez bien qu'à un
moment c'est un peu compliqué pour vous
à l'époque du sketch date ce ne sont pas
mes mes narines ce sont mes ray-ban ça
vous arrive je suis à plomber
c't'histoire bon c'est vrai qu'à un
moment voilà vous aviez du mal à être
reconnu être respectée avec jerry j'ai
l'impression que vous allez trouver
quand même un clan qui vous a accueilli
vous êtes bien vous êtes à l'aise
oui je suis je suis je suis j'ai
toujours été de toute façon très très
heureux de ce que je faisais au moment
où je le faisais jamais de regret ni de
2 mais c'est jamais bien accepter qu'on
arrive d'une d'une famille et qu'on
rentre dans une autre ça c'est toujours
mais aujourd'hui ça va très bien ça va
bien vous trouvez comment votre père en
ce moment là années et étendu sans être
détendue elle ressemble à ça mais sinon
tu m'aimes bien trompeur les bateaux
tous les oiseaux tous trois jours avec
fait les choses qu'il aimait
petite fille ma rue
[Musique]
une à jamais
je les bats toi
lui
[Musique]
un deux trois quarts
carte sado-maso vous devez vous arracher
les poils bon des fois pas les poils un
ouais tu connais l'histoire du suédois
non mais c'était l'histoire le maso qui
di sano fais moi mal lotis dit non merci
ouais toile
et
bien michel je crois que voulait dire un
mot des enfants de beslan donc c'est ses
mille enfants qui ont été otage pendant
trois jours ensuite il ya eu l'assaut de
l'armée russe 360 morts dont 189 enfin
voilà alors l'unicef s'en occuper vous
vous aider l'unicef
voilà c'est à dire qu'on a fait un un
petit spot qui va être diffusé sur
toutes les chaînes où on on parle de ses
enfants c'est évidemment dès qu'il
s'agit d'enfants en s'investissant
samson sont retenus complètement du
meilleur complètement libre et surtout
lorsqu aussi les enfants sont dans un
univers qui suit l'école et l'école
c'est en principe le lieu démocratie tu
as he is est en principe on est dans un
pays comme la russie ou des particuliers
en ossétie du nord qui se veut un pays
démocratique tout s'est passé exactement
l inverse de ce qu'ils avaient
l'intention de montrer au monde donc ça
a été quelque chose d'horrible et
d'insupportable et donc j'espère que ce
message qui va être diffusé sur toutes
les chaînes va toucher les gens parce
que c'est on doit pas oublier les
enfants de beslan et initiatives et ils
ont été otage pendant plusieurs jours et
là je ne voudrais pas qu'il soit otage
de une forme d'indifférence qu'on a ici
chez nous donc il faut vraiment qu on
sache magnéto serge un attentat ne
s'arrête pas parce qu'on n'en parle plus
paul milliers de survivants de beslan
les tortures sont toujours présentes
plus jamais une école doit être prise en
otage
aidons les enfants de beslan à se
libérer de leurs blessures pour qu'ils
retournent à l'école
voilà y'a rien à dire
[Applaudissements]
bien christine je vais vous laisser
filer
[Musique]
m
certains
j'accueille brenda kostin et finit pas
[Applaudissements]
alors on da costa bonsoir vous êtes une
jeune carioca de 22 ans top model
d'envergure internationale notamment
l'image du parfum shalimar de guerlain
mais vous n'êtes pas vraiment à un
mannequin comme les autres vous avez dû
vous battre 10 fois plus que les autres
pour y arriver car vous êtes née sourde
et vous raconter tout ça dans un livre
comme en dépit du handicap
votre rêve d'enfant est devenu réalité
[Applaudissements]
alors brenda est née en 1982 le 8
novembre d'ailleurs c'est son
anniversaire mardi prochain du succès
intéresse et six ou sept mois après
votre naissance votre père se rend
compte de quelque chose il fait le test
de la radio il met la radio à fond et
n'obtient aucune réaction
et malgré l'avis d'un certain nombre de
pédiatres qui disent non elle est tout à
fait normal l'aria lui il est persuadé
en fait que vous êtes sourd de alors vos
parents s'occupent de vous d'une façon
exemplaire ils vous prennent une nounou
particulière ils vous envoient chez le
meilleur orthophoniste du du brésil vous
êtes une enfant très entouré donc on
veut lui apprendre quand elle est toute
petite à dire papa et maman donc on lui
essaye de lui expliquer comment on dit
papa et maman et finalement au bout d'un
moment
après les efforts surhumains le premier
mot qu'elle dit dans sa vie c'est de
coca cola le voilà alors à trois ans et
demi elle est mise dans une école mais
justement ses parents ont pris soin de
ne pas la mettre dans un établissement
pour les sourds et les malentendants
c'est à dire une espèce de ghettos de
sourd muet elle est mise dans une école
normale
[Musique]
elle faisait sa thérapie dans la journée
après l'école et
elle allait dans une école voilà qui est
extraordinaire avec brenda costa c'est
qu'à l'âge de 5 ans elle décide de
devenir mannequin
et elle le fera c'est quand même
extraordinaire va donner à tout le monde
non c'est pas tout le monde mendy
ensuite elle s'épanouit elle apprend à
lire sur les lèvres à laetoli c est là
une bande à la voilà un premier petit
ami voilà et malgré tout ce petit ami se
l'est endroit auquel membres elle aime
bien mais elle continue à la une espèce
de d'opiniâtreté comme ça à réussir son
son rêve sa légende personnelle et
rencontres internes en coûte de l'agencé
élite qui lui fait faire des photos tout
ça mais qui repart à new york et un jour
elle va dans une agence au brésil qui
s'appelle l' agence méga alors elle elle
montre son boucle directeur dit c'est
formidable mais enfin c'est pas possible
quoi elle et elle est sourde eux ça va
être compliqué quand on va l'envoyer
chez les clients on va pas y arriver ça
va être très difficile
hélas en sortant du bureau de ce
directeur c'est miraculeux face elle
elle s'effondre elle elle tombe en
larmes parce que à cause de sa surdité
elle n'a pas été retenue par cette
agence de mannequins méga et passe à ce
moment là le pdg de l'agencé mégalo le
président-directeur général qui a un
fils suhr ag extraordinaire histoire
est-ce que c'est incroyable en même
temps si c'est que ce monsieur il avait
beaucoup de moyens c'est un homme riche
brésilien et en même temps c'est
incroyable parce que lui en fait il a eu
beaucoup de problèmes avec son fils son
fils il était dans une école de pour
sourde il n'avait pas du tout et fatima
sa mère les brainard ville a dit fier
sur escaut tocantins avec avec ses
moyens en fait elle a réussi vraiment
que sa fille elle est
complètement la nuit qu'elle en fait
brenda elle est ce qu'elle est grâce
aussi sur beaucoup grâce à ses partisans
ce câble voilà donc le patron de l'agent
celui dit mais c'est pas un problème mon
fils aussi est sourd donc je vais vous
aider
et d'ailleurs elle sort avec le neveu de
ce léger c'était photographe de mode
elle a quand même pas oublier de sortir
avec le neveu du pdg qui voit là et
alors elle commence à travailler comme
comme mannequin et là vous partez aulas
est extraordinaire c'est à dire quelle
part à new york à l'âge de 20 ans pour
l'agencé élite donc quand une agence
extrêmement importante est à peine
arrivée elle court les castings alors
c'est terrible parce que bon d'abord il
fait froid ça change du brésil il ya la
neige est comme un appât de portables
contrairement aux autres à les obliger à
chaque fois de repasser à la jambe pour
savoir s'il ya du nouveau
les autres fissures tentant d'appeler
sur le portable donc c'est très
compliqué elle a été extrêmement
courageuse imagine quoi elle était sale
et alors en fait elle a dépensé tout son
argent en taxi passe normalement les
filles arrivent devant il ya le premier
jour c'est toujours un peu dur mais elle
prend le mettre au banc brenna comme
elle avait peur déjà c'est faut voir
c'est assez on pousse une autre langue
qu'elle comprend alors là elle comprend
vraiment
rien c'est elle comprend rien alors elle
a dépensé tout l'argent qu'elle a menées
en taxi parce qu'elle prenait des taxi
pour aller c'est extrêmement courageux
parce qu'en plus les gens n'aiment pas
un soin elle dort dans un foyer où il ya
plusieurs mannequine qui habite fille
qui a écrit goba comme quoi c'est à dire
qu'en plus en plus de tous les problèmes
qui avaient a débarqué à new york en
mettant sourde
il ya encore les autres qui unit
n'acquittent me hanter les stocks bien
ce que les to go back en voilà et puis à
force de courage ça commence à marcher
et le 14 juin 2004 vous fait la
couverture du journal
elle est là c'est un petit peu le le
début de la gloire quoi c'est après le
shalimar tout ça puis maintenant c'est
un top modèle qui marche très bien
c'est vrai que son histoire c'est un peu
comme on dit au brésil c'est un peu une
telenovela quoi ouais elle t'a finlande
cas soit store à lyon pour commenter la
nouvelle à elle dit oui mais très
contente que son histoire c'est comme
une telle nouvelle
ouais mais bientôt vous êtes opéré non
la finlande a soit opération il ya une
possibilité oui que brennan va être
opéré le seul problème avec cette
opération c'est que cette opération
s'est pas garanti même si elle est
opérée qu'elle va écouter tout elle va
écouter imaginons en 30%
peut-être mais peut-être pas mais après
il faut penser c'est qu'elle n'a jamais
entendu un bruit de sa vie de sa vie
alors alors pour elle une fac si elle va
entendre après il faut qu'elle fasse une
thérapie une nouvelle thérapie parce que
dès qu'elle va entendre un bruit ça va
être là ça va être un truc de folie
barbelivien car voilà tu t'en sors bien
puisqu'elle est beau père
c'est du producteur mais des implants
copier et c'est tout à fait
extraordinaire et on fait la même chose
pour les yeux
1 les aveugles qu'on peut faire voir et
le choc que subissent les options et
toutes les sauces
il ya un moment de psychothérapie qui
peut durer des semaines des semaines et
des mois
là c'est parce que apprendre tout d'un
coup avoir des bruits qu'on n'a jamais
entendu d'abord c'est a mûri et se
brouille veut dire quelque chose et ça
il faut la prendre il faudrait apprendre
et j'ai très difficile la même chose
pour les les aveugles qui n'ont jamais
vu et la première fois qu'on a fait ça
on avait implanté des des électrodes sur
le cerveau pour que les gens voient
et il voyait à l'envers alors nous on ne
peut pas le savoir
donc ce sont des images et les dessins
qu'il faisait comme qui nous ont fait
comprendre qu'il voyait avec quel
courage à un professeur a c'est tout à
fait que surligner appuyé sur tous et de
joie de vivre
ouais as a service parce que moi la
première fois que l'on m'a parlé de
brennan
j'étais même moi j'étais un peu nerveuse
la première fois aux mains ont veillé à
new york alors pour rencontrer brenda
brenna pour me rencontrer on nous a mis
dans une pièce en étaient les deux on se
regardait un peu comme ça et en fait
c'est quelqu'un dont c'est vraiment
incroyable parce qu'elle est tellement
sensible et à
avant que je dise des choses elle sait
très bien ce que je veux dire et ça et
il ya plein de choses et les traits moi
j'adore me promener avec elle parce que
si je veux comprendre quelque chose elle
lit les lèvres à son maître c'est génial
parce que vraiment c'est j'ai eu un
sourire avenant mais c'est vrai c'est du
hpc chloration parfois les gens disent
que quelqu'un que l'on prend même dans
les shootings parce que les gens pensent
à elle elle écoute pas alors et brenna
c'est vraiment quelqu'un de très
intelligent
elle comprend tout alors elle voit tout
alors c'est plein de fois dans les
shooting avec des gens qui ont dit oui
mais qu'est ce qu'elle fait là où
pourquoi on nous avons elle est belle
mais elle va rien comprendre
est ce assez c'est terrible c'est assez
triste de voir ça parce qu'elle comprend
très bien
non elle vit c'est difficile mais elle
est saine elle aime bien lutté a aucun
problème alors il ya un truc il ya un
truc quand même que je voudrais savoir
le probable si je veut draguer brenda
showbiz est obligé d'être là quoi a dit
comprendre que tu aimais bien que jamais
été avec brenda quand elle a été draguée
quand elle je l'aimais d'ailleurs je
n'ai jamais vu embrasser ce soir
non merci en tous les cas merci d'avoir
été là
c'est publié chez michel
mes yeux
après six ans
ces messieurs
jamais
[Musique]
j'accueille didier barbelivien
[Applaudissements]
il a remis hier soir
bonsoir est ce qu'on peut lire vivier
pour vous présenter aux jeunes
générations que vous êtes le obispo des
années 80 oh mon dieu en restant correct
n'attaque pas bille en tête complètement
parce que obispo il écrit des musiques
moi j'écris votre copie ils copient les
bougies ça commence bien se faire en
train de se faire un pote d'entrée ouais
moi j'écris paroles et musique je veux
pas travailler alors qu il fait que les
projets fatwa je me rendrai pas bien
alors dit si vous revenez ça fait rire
michel c en plus c'est pas sympa mais
j'avoue que ça
alors didier vous revenez avec un album
intitulé envoie les clowns
yes
tous
les
ap
m
city 2
débout
cependant dit il
adam
[Applaudissements]
sabine hadad jean françois rime
c'est dany boon j'ai oublié la raison de
ma fille c'est leur prime
et oui les lanceurs de balloon qui force
le cartoon comme avatar ou donnez vous
heureusement que tu es là quand même pas
de diplôme de rien alors vous pensez
qu'en manque de clown
oui c'est quand j'en vois tous les jours
à la télé où j'aurai télévisée de
l'ouémé on en manque un peu oui pâques
au journal télévisé des nez rouges ça
ferait plaisir un peu partout en ce
moment la renvoie les clowns donc c'est
la dernière chanson de l'album la clovis
un gros challenge demande de respecter
ce jeu marche devrait pas être bon
public
après je suis coincé j'arrive plus à
trop bien les ordres du service le
samedi on voit des clowns ses dernières
chansons de l'album la première c'est je
crois en toi alors c'est marrant parce
que d'un seul coup vous qu'on connaît
bien commun à votre âge et à l'heure
qu'il est et alors qu'est vous faites
une chanson sur dieu quoi c'est pourquoi
pas parce que c'est un recadrage
non pas du tout au regard de jean tiberi
c'est pas sympa tu me laisses pas plus
de tout ça
puis c'est essentiel mais qui dort pas
non plus leurs pages compris j'ai
compris j'ai compris non se dire
pourquoi pas se dire il y en a qui
revendique d'être musulman juif pourquoi
jeux annoncés par mois je tiens comme
moi je l'aurais pas dit mais c'est
marrant vous le disiez maintenant quoi
il faut un temps pour tout je lui ai
toujours bon de le dire voilà ouais je
sais pas si c'est le moment mais c'est
l'envi en tout cas alors vous dites il
n'est pas politiquement correct de dire
que l'on est chrétien et que l'on croit
en dieu tu veux des samoa ouais bon
attendez d'avoir happé pierre joannon
que j'avais vous avez dit ça mais je
veux savoir dans la baule plus à dans la
vole plus c'est possible aujourd'hui des
bêtises on a nos sources à la baule plus
c'est quoi ton blanc a le droit d'écrire
de la boule de droit m kraton de métier
qu'est ce que tu dis merde je tombais
concert qui veulent chier quand j'ai vu
plus ne dit pas c'est qu'elle journal si
l'on enlève la beauce corman ca 2008
s'abonner c'est énorme la voix
qu'honnêtement je sais pas honnêtement
moi je vous dis ah c'est pas tellement
anti politiquement correct de dire qu'on
est chrétiens moi je l'avais vu des
années à télé ça du tout - salut moi
qu'ils ont 100 foot non je le sais ouais
on a ça en commun oui c'est vrai alors
il est toujours dans ce journal de la
baule plus parce qu'il ya des choses qui
arrivent à parler de croisic magazine de
jose - politiquement au journal
concurrent a cessé à 5 il ya des choses
moins politiquement correct dans la
baule des russes
vous avez déclaré philippe de villiers
est un homme ça quelqu'un dont la france
a besoin vous dit ça au moment où
philippe de villiers tente de récupérer
l'électorat lepéniste en disant que la
france est victime de l'islamisation et
tout ça et qui s'associe avec le maire
d'orange
monsieur bompard excusez moi votre homme
ça moi personnellement je trouve qu'il
est pas sain voilà mon cher thierry moi
moi j'essaie de parler des hommes comme
je les connais moi pas en tant que
politique supin politique
je les connais dans leur vie privée leur
vie intime et ski ce que je peux aimer
en eux je vous posais la question est ce
que vous êtes d'accord quand philippe de
villiers dit qu'il craint l'islamisation
de la france
moi je la crains pas mes sentiments que
la france est en train de s'islamiser
non sinon je chanterai pas je crois en
toi mais non mais vous remet alors il
faut lui dire si vous le connaissez
philippe de villiers très bien juste un
ami à vous il faut lui dire qu'on aime
bien on n'a rien contre lui mais que
l'islamisation du haillan ça sent un peu
le jean marie le pen light qua non reste
pas des fachos mais des hommes de
politiques de droite
quelquefois maladroit je me souviens
quand il s'est présenté aux
présidentielles en étant contre
l'avortement et contre michel gély
comment tu vas être élu président de la
république dans un pays où il ya 53 % de
femmes étude présente contre
l'avortement c'est ridicule
mais je veux dire quelquefois le
parcours des hommes
politique peut aussi avoir un nez rouge
ouais sur le nez mais moi je préférais
quand vous étiez copain avec sarkozy et
christian clavier
je sais ce que bon c'est pas des mecs
mais enfin non mieux c'est toujours
beaucoup plus les jours comme pas avec
ça qu'ils sont devenus jean reno ami
avec nicolas sarkozy oui bien sûr car
nicolas sarkozy vous pensez quoi de la
façon qui gère la crise des banlieues en
ce moment ben moi je suis pas je voulais
déjà dit je suis pas un spécialiste mais
je pense que quand il parle de
la racaille c'est qu'elle existe enfin
un peu quelque part sinon c'est pas un
bonhomme a employé des mots comme ça si
ça n'existait pas et je me dis que les
mots changent de sens aussi quand
j'étais étudiant j'allais aux manifs de
gaulle disait c'est la chienlit
ouais aujourd'hui sarko dit c'est la
racaille pourquoi vrai mais il y en a ça
et vous pensez que la façon dont il a
géré cette crise là c'est une bonne
façon dire je vais karchériser je vais
penser que c'est un langage de
karchériser je pense pas que c'est ce
qu'il ait voulu dire je pense qu'il
voulait envoyer les canons à eau mais
pas le karcher césarien le karcher sur
un truc comme l'esplanade de nanterre
n'en sera rien ça mais vous pensez qu'en
banlieue faut envoyer les clowns à ce
serait super
son père
au revoir psf vous oui depuis longtemps
j'avais vrai qu'on paye trop d'impôts si
mais bon écoute on va voir on va faire
une interview florent pagny
ils paient beaucoup d'impôts autant que
vous thierry ouais vous pouvez passer
des gueux l'âge tous ses impôts qu'on
doit payer non pas du tout s'ils sont
bien utilisés c'est avec plaisir fait
pas que c'est exagéré qu'on devrait tous
partir en patagonie finalement non moi
je suis français je resterai français
quel que soit le taux d'imposition
ça vous fait pas mal au coeur qu'on
donne 60 % de notre salaire pour
construire des écoles alors qu'on va pas
à l'école
bah non pourquoi les écoles servent aux
autres n'en ont pas du tout vous seriez
prêt à signer une pétition
pas d'impôts pour les artistes non mais
pas d'impôts pour
ceux qui ont les plus bas salaires oui
ça vous dirait de chanter je suis contre
une chanson qui explique que l'ieseg
c'est dégueulasse avec sardou et les
florent pagny non je serais pour je
trouve ça un impôt sur sur l'impôt je
trouve ça un peu injuste un peu ridicule
un peu pénalisant je crois que ça fait
partir beaucoup de gens de ce pays je
trouve ça dommage
ce à quoi alain pour payer moins
d'impôts vous trichez à n'ont jamais non
non je suis trop nul en calcul pour
tricher n'ont pensé qu'on serait plus
heureux si on payer moins d'impôts je
pense que si on supprime pas l'impôt
pour les plus bas salaires je vois pas
comment ce pays peut se relever et
comment on peut retrouver une
consommation et comment je suis
halluciné de voir j'étais allé avec
sarkozy dans le pas de calais 2 on a
fait une tournée pendant trois jours à
visiter des des familles et je sais pas
comment ces gens s'en tire avec le peu
d'argent qu'ils gagnent et encore le
mois et demi d'impôts qu'on leur prend
sur leur salaire je sais pas comment ils
font
vous avez fait des chansons des fois
juste pour payer vos impôts pour nourrir
ma famille pas pour payer mes impôts de
penser que l'état aura notre liberté de
penser à la fin j'espère pas signaux
florent pagny vous l'aimez bien j'aime
beaucoup c'est mon voisin à la campagne
ouais si terrible dont en effet philippe
de villiers nicolas sarkozy un
subsaharien vié et florent plein ici
vous
là
au pinceau blind test
[Musique]
pour jouer vous
rappel génie del pino
[Applaudissements]
oui
bonsoir fait funny people tous les
samedis à 18h casque / fenty vie voilà
une bonne raison de regarder fenty 20 dj
ça va très bien d'être contente d'être
là très mécontent de vous avoir cette
forte au blind test non je crois que je
suis véritablement nul ah bon ben vous
avez demandé à vis et l'a vu tout à
l'heure les les réponses je les ai le
droit de regarder les réponses du blind
test et la dernière fois qu'elle est
venue alice taglioni elle a trouvé
l'ultra banco donc je crois que vous
êtes dans la bonne équipe
sauf que je ne me rappelle absolument
pas des réponses évidemment c'est
dommage ce domaine la première pour
malgré dix que j'appelle michaël
canitrot
[Musique]
non
complication mais m
le calme
[Musique]
comment ça va à michael ça va très bien
les américaines un merci thierry dereux
merci je connaissais pas je serai mignon
et toi attend sur un voiture et ce
prêtre plaire et tu réponds aux blinds
ouest quand les prêts michael bon sens
nival alors le principe est simple donc
dans un premier temps c'est le par
équipes l'équipe de bernard debré comme
sur l'équipe de didier barbelivien
c'est des luttes intestines de la droite
ça c'est mairie on est mal en bouche de
dans un heureux et après ça sera le
chacun pour sa gueule on est prêt
morceau numéro 1 mickaël
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur hôtel california merci
bien donc la voyez c'est comme ça veut
dire le nom de l'interprète
la musique c'est tout azimut c'est ça
c'est lui qui l'a choisi c'est canitrot
qu'il a choisi d'accord on passe au
numéro 2 mickaël normal
non
je suis
j'ai mis en vente qui veut de torches et
la radio nostalgie qui s'appelle
christophe nicolas je dis moi tu
m'invites je marchais plein de fois ici
c'est l'élu dans l'équipe delanoë qui
avait les réponses permis à michael
manama
lors de talence ray-ban et ben non c'est
pas ça
il a passé il m'a trouvé toutes les
réponses tout sourire et par email
au lieu de passer son certificat
d'études est donné dans les boîtes dans
les années 80 il a par aillleurs années
80 attention michael
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bravo dit non non elle ne s'en souvient
pas puis aucune mémoire c'est très bien
rappelé à dieu il suffit d'une note de
vigueur
le
m
on continue michael sont conscients oui
non
m
non moi moi je pense que lé très bonne
année quand elle est devenue la première
fois elle a gagné le blind test donc
aujourd'hui je pense pas qu'elle se
souvienne des répondants sur l'intro de
batterie non mais ouais c'est vraiment
faim donc ça fait 3 3 quand même laurent
lahaye bb bag est une désolation
l'allons attention michael taisez vous
[Musique]
tyson rêve
m
les cas 1.25 côté parce que la série
matt asay
[Applaudissements]
alors on dit elle est à dire
bon alors fait un petit bout
[Musique]
deux immenses
m
or
oh
serge cyr n'a pas répété je n'aurais pas
dû voir ça ça me gironde maintenant on
dit ça ils sont avec 41,2 me serge et
gavin centre
[Applaudissements]
catherine le point comme stéphanie tu le
dis toi sera à l'eurovision bas dans le
4 x et fanny cas là
carmat ce point ça souffle et de partout
pour l'onu dont 3,3 alors c'est très
bagarrer ce soir mickaël
ça
je mets ma fille a dit en même temps et
la fille qui la dit non jeudi un peu
plus c'est bon alors si c'est fanny
petit replay je suis d'ailleurs
nicole
4 partout pour avoir tué sa femme quatre
ans mais c'est très bagarre et c'était
intéressant
alors bon état et qui désormais 4,4 et
nous continuons michael à toi ça
m'inquiète plus seulement quatre cadres
oui merde comme il s'appelle guy ritchie
lionel richie
attention continue notre baffie en plus
séduisante elle confie ouais c'est quand
même autre chose que de filles excuses
allons-y oui
la lta tu m'as tranché sur le nom n'est
pas monté chez eux on peut voir monsieur
ripley quand je veux
ça
oui
on dira
alain gibout comme de taille dans la
gamme allant garros a cédé points qui
passe en continu michael reagan
oui mais
serge
moi jamais
ouais
c'est super cross polo
ça sentait la bombe les faits soient
bien donc à la fin du par équipes quatre
points pour l'équipe du professeur debré
et du grand ouest
l'équipe de didier marie
[Applaudissements]
maintenant nous passons à des choses
oui vous allez gagner vraiment pas ce
chacun pour sa gueule ça c'est vous
connaissez madelin qui ça à la main de
son amie on va aimer qui lui partisan du
chacun pour sa gueule justement on
arrive au libéralisme absolu la faisait
de comptes en série à une équipe il ya
plus de solidarité ans et c'est la
jungle
mais on y va donc attention le banco
amateur 2 secondes
à
laurent laurent blanc tu as ta place
je félicite pas
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lui toujours par nos chats pessah la
dernière ligne james ingram six mois je
vais pas trouver mais il nous choque que
genre sur la dernière ligne droite tuez
tous j'arrive ma chérie il ya un super
bon coup on allait supprimer super banco
il
sister's sister sledge
bien sister sledge bravo monsieur bardot
on continue avec le méga banques ou
michael
[Musique]
world tour
[Applaudissements]
thelma houston way
et maintenant mesdames et messieurs
l'ultra banco celui ou celle qui va
trouver sera la star absolue de la
soirée donc avis tu sais que d'habitude
tu trouves ultra banco donc c'est le
moment c'est près tout le monde est
plein grands yeux ronds c'est une
arnaque
attention l'ultra banco michael
bien
tous
non
la star est née
comment tu t'appelles stéphanie stéphane
tu as trouvé beaucoup de choses ce soir
j'ai peut-être le nouveau laurent baffie
[Applaudissements]
le coz
là
ok
oh
hazard mezzanine volume 4 dames
messieurs
[Applaudissements]
et voilà c'est fini c'était tout le
monde en parle
jean louis borg avec l'album sacré
on s'y perd le single sera battu
il est en cause
les dix-sept joie
robbie williams non merci laurent
jeanneau julie et guillaume depardieu
les rois maudits à partir de lundi soir
à 40 c'est sur france 2
puis je vais
jusqu'à boléro money voilà et jeannot
coffret cd/dvd succès confidences
sortie le 21 novembre christine
deviers-joncour désabre maudit date
publiques chez pharos chaque marine
pierre lebreux merci bernard gardon sous
serment ou la fin 2015
sas coach et tout le monde c'est au
siège midi à vis et brioni comice
cardiaques des chevaliers
s avec en plus benoît magimel
dean place voilà le 9 novembre juste
après les chevaliers du ciel en drainant
vicat ce fait pitié pour les innocents
c'est chez michel lafon
messieurs les familles elles merci leur
double album je te donnerai michel
amitié sincère et bernard murat au
théâtre edouard vii voilà plus la
campagne de mobilisation en faveur des
enfants de beslan voilà brenda costa
pelle du silence c'est chez michel lafon
didier barbelivien
envoie les clowns et ça sort le 7
novembre au blender
mignot merci fjfnb paul cluzel pdg
carcassonne tv inverse du 12 novembre à
la halle aux bleds piège viviane castro
merci l'album est jan innés l'alcazar
bolide 4 et le générique de fin et
extraits d'albums farmiga
j'ai tellement à part rendez vous la
semaine prochaine
merci
[Applaudissements]
alors
[Musique]
m
ump
il
je vais
au niveau
il attend
[Musique]
hélas
il
m
[Musique]
il
et
[Musique]
non
il est
à
et
puis
[Musique]
m
il
non
[Musique]
hélas
et l'ensemble
[Musique]
k
une assemblée
[Musique]
dans la région